[Musique]
Esther Duflo, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Bonsoir d'abord. Merci de de me
recevoir. Je m'appelle Asterher Duflot.
Je suis professeur d'économie euh au MIT
à Boston et au Collège de France à
Paris. Euh j'ai fondé il y a maintenant
20 ans un laboratoire qui est vraiment
un réseau euh qui s'appelle le
laboratoire d'action contre la pauvreté
et
ça peut être un laboratoire, un réseau,
un mouvement. C'est à peu près 1000
chercheurs à travers le monde qui
travaillent avec des partenaires de
terrain. Ça peut être des ONG, des
gouvernements, des activistes, des
entreprises aussi euh pour les aider à
évaluer l'impact de ce qu'ils font pour
aider les plus pauvres du monde dans
leur dans leur vie. Donc tout pour
aider, il y a des tas de
d'interventions, de politique
à destination des plus pauvres. Euh
est-ce que ces programmes marchent ?
Est-ce qu'il marche pas ? S'il marche
pas, pourquoi ? Et comment comprendre la
source des problèmes que ces programmes
essayent de de résoudre ?
Accessoirement, vous avez le prix Nobel
d'économie.
Voilà, ça fait pas partie de ma
présentation, je dirais. Mais
vous parlez combien de langues ? Quatre
langues.
Euh, j'en parle peut-être aucune très
bien,
surtout français. C'est ça.
Vous êtes de nationalisé naturalisé
pardon depuis 2012 américaine.
Oui.
Il est en train de te demander de
recadrer le le plan large un chouilla
vers le haut. Est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on peut commencer les gars ? Bon,
c'est la rentrée. Il y en a deux qui
vont se faire tirer les oreilles
aujourd'hui. Et donc accessoirement,
vous parlez russe ?
Oui.
Anglais ?
Français ? Un petit peu.
Un peu.
Et j'ai oublié la 4è
allemand. Mais alors là vraiment plus
bien, je pense.
Shune
Shun
Shun c'est Shun. On a décidé de faire
notre rentrée avec vous parce que les
sujets économiques, les sujets de
pauvreté,
comme par hasard, c'est en train de
revenir un peu au goût du jour.
Et donc la la déjà comment vous percevez
la pauvreté qu'il y a à l'heure actuelle
aux États-Unis ?
Bah ce qui est frappant aux États-Unis,
c'est un pays qui a connu une croissance
économique relativement robuste au cours
des 20 30 dernières années, mais où le
revenu moyen et le revenu médian est
resté
quasiment inchangé.
Donc toute la croissance économique ou
presque toute la croissance économique a
été capturée par les plus les plus
fortunés.
dans le même temps. Euh et c'est une
économie qui a été soumise à des
chocs de de de tout ordre. D'abord, il y
a eu le choc de l'entrée de la Chine
dans le commerce international qui a
fait par exemple que des gens qui
travaillaient euh par exemple pour pour
faire des meubles, des villes entières
où les gens travaillaient pour faire des
meubles se sont trouvés avec leurs
sources de
d'activité et d'emploi qui ont disparu.
Et du coup, il y a eu
euh une non seulement une pas de
régression de la pauvreté comme on
aurait dû avoir avec une avec
la croissance économique, mais plutôt un
accroissement et aussi une
dureté de plus en plus grande de la vie
de de personnes de de dans ces villes
parce que
ça se matérialise comment cette dureté ?
Ça se commence ça se matérialise par une
consommation hyper acérée de finanil
ou de d'une molécule autre
des gens des gens qui vivent dans leur
camping-car, des bidonville, des
quartiers entiers complètement
ruinés. Ce qui est vraiment très
frappant aux États-Unis et qui a été
tout à fait unique dans les nations
riches, c'est le fait que depuis euh
même avant le Covid euh depuis plusieurs
années, euh l'espérance de vie des euh
des des gens entre 40 et 60 ans diminué
au lieu de au lieu de au lieu
d'augmenter.
C'est ce que Anqua et Angusitan ont
appelé les morts de désespoir,
c'est-à-dire les gens qui qui meurent
dans le entour de autour de 40 50 60 ans
d'une combinaison de d'overdose,
de d'empoisonnement par l'alcool, de
suicide ou de mort violente par arme.
Donc c'est quand même un un phénomène
assez remarquable
dans le mauvais sens aux États-Unis
qui est attribué à attribuable à un
certain nombre de causes mais dont en
particulier par exemple ce qui peut se
passer quand imaginez une ville en
Caroline du Nord ou qui était où
l'industrie était essentiellement les
meubles.
La la Chine entre dans le dans le
concert du concert du commerce
international, les se met à produire des
meubles. C'est cette entreprise, toutes
les entreprises de meubles de cette
ville disparaissent. Les gens en fait
ont du mal à partir. On a l'impression
que les États-Unis sont un endroit où
les gens sont extrêmement mobiles et
cetera. Mais en fait, c'est pas vrai.
Euh, depuis euh euh entre la juste
l'immédiate après-guerre et aujourd'hui,
la mobilité géographique aux États-Unis
a extrême a diminué. Donc les gens ne se
déplacent pas tant que ça en fait. Donc,
les gens veulent pas partir ou ne
peuvent pas partir peuvent pas parce que
ils sont propriétaires de leur maison
qui a déjà perdu de la valeur. Donc, ils
peuvent pas, ils ont pas de quoi s'en
acheter une autre. Il y a pas de système
pour garder leurs enfants s'ils sont
s'ils vont dans une ville, ils sont
obligés de rester à côté. Euh et puis de
tout ils sont euh euh un petit peu soit
coincés là où ils sont, soit simplement
c'est la seule vie qui qu'ils
envisagent. Et du coup donc ils perdent
leur emploi, ils partent pas. Comme ils
perdent leur emploi et qu'il y a pas eu
de remplacement, il y a pas eu de
remplacement de ses revenus par une
politique sociale très très active aux
États-Unis, euh le le il consomment
plus. Du coup, les gens qui leur
vendaient des sandwichs et cetera. ces
ces emplois disparaissent aussi et
finalement il y a une espèce d'implosion
de cette ville euh qui euh euh perd euh
encore beaucoup plus d'emplois que
simplement les emplois originels dans le
secteur de l'ameublement.
pour rebondir. Donc là là on a vu
Caroline du Nord, le Massachusett, vous
connaissez un petit peu. On part de
l'autre côté, côté Californie, côté San
Francisco, côté Los Angeles, euh Santa
Catarina ou la
Il se passe quoi là-bas ? C'est parce
que ça produit plus de meuble ou c'est
parce que il y a l'augmentation des
loyers qui qui éclate ? Ça ça c'est à
cause de quoi ce qui se passe ? Pourquoi
il y a tant de gens qui erent comme des
zombies dans les rues ? Pourquoi il y a
Est-ce que c'est le même mécanisme que
sur la la Caroline du Nord ?
Non, c'est très différent de la Caroline
du Nord parce que justement il c'est pas
qu'il produisait des meubles au départ.
En Californie, il y a des emplois, il y
a une économie qui est très vive. en
Californie, le problème, il y a
probablement plusieurs problèmes, mais
un problème
cœur de la Californie, c'est vraiment le
problème des logements. C'est-à-dire que
ça a été extrêmement attirant et
justement, c'est aussi pour ça que les
gens de Caroline du Nord ne peuvent pas
quitter la Caroline du Nord parce que
s'ils allaient en Californie pour vendre
des meubles et ou être gardien de
sécurité dans une boutique de meubles,
il faudrait qu'il puisse se loger
quelque part. En Californie, c'est
impossible. en en particulier dans dans
dans les villes en Californie, les il y
a une une résistance très très forte à
aux nouvelles constructions. Il y a des
lois assez rigides qui limitent les
constructions les constructions de
nouveaux logements. Il y a pas vraiment
d'effort de ou de volonté politique au
niveau local de de changer de changer
ces lois. Et du coup les les prix de
l'immobilier ont explosé et il y a
simplement pas assez de logement pour
tout le monde. Donc quand il y a pas
assez de logement pour tout le monde, au
bout d'un moment, ben il y a des gens
qui sont dans la rue.
On va remonter dans le temps.
Je vous demanderais de me donner votre
point de vue sur la crise de 2008 et
ensuite des mécanismes qui ont été
utilisés par les banques, différentes
banques centrales et en particulier Ben
Bernank à l'époque.
La crise de 2008, c'est quoi ? Vous avez
vu vous avez vu le film le fameux film
The Big Short.
Ça c'était c'était caviar ça quand même.
Et c'est bien fait non ? Ça vous
connaissez deux trois salles de marché ?
Vous connaissez des traders un petit peu
? Il y a pas du tout.
The Big Short,
nous on connait deux trois traders,
c'est ça ressemble à ça mais comme il
faut.
Donc 2008, la crise des sub prime les
mécanismes employés derrière pour
éponger ou mettre la le caca sous le
tapis, la poussière sous le tapis et
ensuite comment ça a continué jusqu'en
2022. OK.
Alors, je vais commencer par préfacer ça
pour dire que moi je ne suis pas
macroéconomiste, je suis spécialiste
d'économie du développement. Euh je
travaille essentiellement sur les pays
pauvres et en plus que ça en plus de ça
plutôt sur des sujets euh plus sur des
sujets micros et des sujets de politique
sociale. Donc euh
je peux vous couper ?
Oui.
Vous m'autorisez ?
Comment on fait quand on a la tête dans
le guidon, quand on travaille sur la
pauvreté sans connaître les mécanismes
macroéconomiques qui génèrent cette
pauvreté ?
Alors, d'abord euh l'avantage de
l'économie par rapport à d'autres
disciplines scientifiques, c'est que la
culture de base en économie est quand
même assez large. C'est-à-dire on se
lance pas dans quelque chose dans une
matière sans avoir après les autres.
Donc bien que je ne sois pas
macroéconomiste, j'ai une disons une
connaissance de base de ce que les
macroéconomistes connaissent au niveau
au niveau disons euh de quelqu'un qui a
fait une thèse. Euh première chose.
Deuxième chose, les les mécanismes
macroéconomiques derrière la pauvreté,
personne ne les connaît, surtout pas les
macroéconomistes.
Donc la différence avec moi, c'est que
au moins moi je sais que je ne les
connais pas, ce qui est plutôt un
avantage, je pense.
La troisième chose, c'est que même quand
on connaît pas les mécanismes, même bien
qu'on ne connaisse pas, bien qu'on
comprenne pas bien, on comprend deux
trois petites choses, mais qu'on
comprenne mal les mécanismes
macroéconomiques en particulier, on a on
a on regarde derrière, on arrive à
regarder derrière mais on a du mal
certainement les macroéconomistes ont
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à prédire ce
qui va se produire.
Euh vous me terrifiez là
ça non. Ben non, vous
me terrifiez. Vous savez pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ?
Parce que j'ai l'impression que ceux
censés connaître la macroéconomie
qui regardent vers l'avant en fait ils
regardent pas vers l'avant, ils
inventent des nouveaux mots. Genre les
les pas les décroissants, les
déconsommateurs
des des mécanismes comme ça. C'estàd que
j'ai l'impression d'avoir un chauffeur
de bus qui regarde derrière mais qui
regarde jamais devant.
Euh
Daniel Cohen vient de vient de décéder à
feu Daniel Cohen à la fin du à la fin du
du mois d'août regretter Daniel Cohen
qui était mon mon mentor qui me disait
qui nous disait les économistes de toute
façon ils prévoit ils font en général
des théories qui qui sont déjà caducues
au moment où il les où ils les
mettent en place parce que il forcément
ils regardent le passé. Donc au moment
où Maltus nous parle de mécanismes de
surpopulation et cetera, le problème de
surpopulation est déjà fini. Donc je
crois que c'est un problème qui est
vieux comme le monte avec l'économie.
Euh
vous connaissez le proverbe ?
Euh je sais pas, j'allais en citer un
mais je sais pas si c'est le proverbe.
Allez-y allez-y.
C'est plutôt
c'est avec les astrologues ou pas ?
Voilà, c'est avec les astrologues.
Voilà, c'est John Kenneth Galbret qui
disait que la la la prédiction
économique existe pour donner un pour
donner un bon une bonne réputation aux
pour pour améliorer la réputation des
astrologues.
Vous êtes sûr du du proverbe ? Parce que
moi j'en ai un légèrement différent.
C'est Dieu a créé ce les
macroéconomistes, les prévisionnistes
économiques pour que les astrologues se
sentent moins seuls.
Ouais. celui que je connaissais, la
citation que je connaissais était un
petit peu un petit peu différente, mais
peut-être que une fois qu'il est tombé
sur son beau mot, il a décidé de le de
le recycler de différentes manières. Une
autre façon de voir ça, euh le le FMI
qui est une institution tout à fait
raisonnable et responsable a des
centaines d'économistes qui sont en
charge de prédiction,
d'anticipation ou de prédiction.
Allez, un peu les deux. Now casting,
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ? Qu'est-ce qui va se passer
dans 6 mois ? c'est dans un an et puis
probablement de l'anticipation à plus
long terme. Euh le le magazine Z
économiste avait fait un article rigolo
où il comparait la la
précision ou le l'exactitude des
prédictions du FMI à d'autres mécanismes
que l'économiste proposait. 1, c'est de
choisir au hasard entre 2 % et 4 % pour
la croissance à venir dans l'année
suivante. De c'est de garder exactement
la même que l'année dernière et 3, c'est
toujours trois.
Et euh donc après les trois prédictions
de Z économiste, on peut calculer à
partir de la vérité la la l'erreur de
prédiction. Puis on peut faire la même
chose pour les prédictions du FMI. et le
prédiction du FMI n'est pas meilleure
que les les prédictions du du de Z
économiste. Donc on voit bien que les
nos capacités les capacités de
préduction euh de ce dont c'est le
boulot de de prédire ne sont pas très
bonnes. De manière intéressante, le FMI
un un chercheur du FMI avait publié
aussi un rapport, un article euh pour
montrer la capacité pour étudier la
capacité du FMI à prédire les crises
spécifiquement.
Et donc ils avaient regardé dans les
épisodes de récession donc où par
définition un épisode de récession où
c'est l'économie le le l'économie baisse
enfin le le PIB baisse. Ils avaient
regardé les prédictions du FMI 1 an
avant puis 6 mois dans l'année de la
récession, 3 mois dans l'année de la
récession. Et ce qui montre déjà que
c'est que 1 an avant le alors qu'on sait
que c'est zéro, le FMI prédit à peu près
2 % de croissance. 6 mois dans l'année
de la récession, on est encore à de la
croissance positive et même à euh à la
fin au 3e trimestre de l'année, le euh
on est le FMI surestime encore les les
perspectives de croissance puisquil il y
a pas de croissance. Bon pour donc
c'était quand même donc le FMI manque
systématiquement toutes les toutes les
récessions spécifiquement pour ne pas
donner un mauvais une mauvaise
réputation au FMI. Il compare aussi le
les prédictions des d'un consens le
consensus des prédicateurs et les
consensus des prédicteurs est tout à
fait aussi mauvais que que le FMI. Donc
on a on a du mal à la prédiction c'est
difficile surtout surtout l'avenir comme
le veut comme le veut la blague. Donc
tout ça c'était pour disons des
préliminaires pour dire que
bienvenue sur Syerview.
Bienvenue sur Syerview. Merci. et pour
pouvoir et pour dire que
je sais pas si mon opinion sur la les
les mécanismes conduit à la crise de
2008 sont plus euh
à prendre avec des pincettes hein et
mais
ce qui s'est produit, ce qu'on a
l'impression qu' s'est produit avec le
avec le recul, c'est que
ça a démarré avec la crise des ce
parce que il y avait les les les
il y avait l'idée très fortement
répandue que le le marché immobilier ne
baisserait jamais partout en même temps
et que donc on pouvait toujours les les
traders pouvaient toujours arbitrer un
marché contre l'autre et en particulier
un panier de de bien de marché de
l'immobilier était un investissement qui
ne tomberait pas. Or, c'était sans
compter sur le fait que les gens euh en
particulier les les les ménages les
moins riche, c'était euh endetté au-delà
de ce qu'il pouvait soutenir parce que
il y avait une industrie qui poussait
euh qui qui poussait dans leur direction
des produits qui étaient pas
soutenables.
Qu'est-ce que vous appelez l'industrie
qui poussait ? Vous parlez des gars de
The Big Short qui collectionnit les
voitures, qui qui collectionnait les bar
à stripties et ainsi de suite.
L'industrie qui pousse, non ? C'est
enfin oui, ça ça va de là jusque au au
au gars dans sa banque dont le job c'est
de de de vendre des prêts.
Il y a il y a pas d'organisme de
régulation de cette industrie, des gens
avec les pieds sur terre pour l'intérêt
général.
Il y a ça existe ou pas ? Je fais mon
candide à
à cette époque-là, ça n'existait pas du
tout. C'estàd justement parce qu'il y
avait pas cette idée que c'était un
que c'était un risque
euh enfin qu'il y avait un un risque de
de surendettement. C'était pas quelque
chose sur personne avait je crois
honnêtement que personne n'avait
vraiment les yeux là-dessus, ni les
économistes.
Les agences de notation peut-être
les agences de notation euh non les
agences de enfin je sais même pas si
c'est leur leur job pour être honnête
aux agences de notation globalement mais
en plus
actuair
les les actuaires. Il aurait fallu
surtout qu'il y ait une une
agence qui qui soit capable de dire
"Vous n'avez pas le droit d'offrir un un
prêt à quelqu'un qui dont les les
quand les les mensualités de
remboursement vont excéder la capacité
de cette personne à rembourser. surtout
si ça va pas se passer l'année prochaine
parce que ce que les gens ce que ce qui
était très populaire c'est ces espèces
de jumbo mortgage où les gens
ne payaient pas grand-chose au départ
et puis au bout de 1 an ou 2 ans
commencer à avoir des des taux variables
des taux des taux variables mais qui
commençaient à zéro
genre un peu ce qui ce qu' a souscrit le
gouvernement français il y a pas très
longtemps c'est ça
je sais pas si le je sais pas si la la
l'analogie est est valable ou pas, mais
là en l'occurrence,
ton état peut pas faire faillite
euh
Non, mais parce que euh quand on vend
ces produits là à un individu,
un individu qui est peut-être pas très
éduqué, don la la
qui a pas qui qui est qui est
vulnérable, qui fait confiance à
l'autorité,
on peut pas et c'est vraiment une
injustice profonde. de s'attendre à ce
que cette personne-là
puisse dire non quand on lui propose
quelque chose ou voilà, il peut avoir sa
maison ou alors refinancer la maison
dans lequelle il est déjà. Euh il y a
pas de il y aura il y a pas d'intérêt à
payer pendant 2 ans et puis après ça
explose à un niveau qui est même pas qui
est même pas et les qui est même pas où
ce sera impossible de de rembourser.
En France, il y a pas eu des
collectivités locales qu'on souscrit des
prêts à ta variables. Il y a pas des
gens en Hongrie, par exemple qui ont
souscrit des prêts indexés sur le franc
suisse. Il y a pas eu Je veux bien Je
veux bien que le permettez-moi le
l'expression que le Pékin Landa, on lui
propose Mons et merveille de souscrire X
crédit immobilier pour acheter X maison
et on lui dit "T'inquiète pas mon pote,
le prix du marché d'immobilier va
monter. T'inquiète, t'inquiète,
t'inquiète."
Bon d'accord, c'est c'est un public
vulnérable où il y a le début des sub
prime qui qui a commencé grâce à la
vulnérabilité de ces gens-là et la
titrisation de ces prêts là pour masquer
la
voilà la titrisation cit pas seulement
pour masquer laisation c'est parce que
les gens pensaient les les les gens qui
titrisaient pensaient vraiment je pense
honnêtement parce qu'ils avaient regardé
le passé et sans se dire il y a il y a
quelque chose on a changé le système ils
sont pas rendus compte en fait qu'ils
avaient changé le système de manière
manière à rendre l'ensemble
de de des prêts à cette franche de
population euh
pas solvable. Quand tant que c'est une
personne est solvable et pas l'autre, la
titrisation, ce qu'on appelle en anglais
les morgate security, c'est ça paraît de
l'or.
Avant avant les mortgages, c'est quoi
déjà un emprunt ninja ?
Ah je sais pas.
Nocom.
Ah no
no no income no job, c'est ça. Je sais
pas, je crois que c'est ça l'acronyme
mais la question mais la la mais c'est
la c'est surtout la forme des taux
d'intérêt et ça je sais même je pense
que c'est je sais pas en fait je suis
pas sûre mais je pense que c'est illégal
en France. C'est pas juste le fait que
le taux est variable, c'est que le taux
change au au cours du temps de et va
augmenter. C'estàd on commence avec un
produit d'appel qui a un taux proche de
zéro
avec la perspective que d'ici 2 ans le
taux les taux d'intérêt augmenteront.
C'est pas c'est pire que variable.
Bon, la crise des subprime 2008,
donc la prise des subprime 2008 nous
nous amène à cette qui finalement voilà,
il y avait trop de de trop d'emprunt qui
pouvaient pas être remboursés qui a
conduit à une exp une
à à une crise bancaire qui s'est traduit
par une crise économique. Ce qui était
intéressant quand même par rapport à ce
qui s'était passé dans le passé parce
que le fait que ce soit Bern qui était
aux commande et que Bern se trouvait à
être un expert de la crise de 29
euh l'a conduit à
nous a a conduit les le à la fois aux
États-Unis et puis dans le dans le G20
par exemple adopté une stratégie
différente de celle de 2930 où tout le
monde s'était replié sur soi-même,
c'était lancé dans une espèce de de
guerre
commerciale qui avait renforcé les
effets de la crise de 29. Alors que là,
il y a eu la la une coopération
internationale qui a évité qu'on qu'on
qu'on arrive en 2008, qui était quand
même la crise la plus grave peut-être
depuis depuis ce depuis 29 dans de
certaine manière, mais on a évité que ce
soit aussi grave. Par contre, on a fait
d'autres erreurs euh et en particulier
celle de vouloir
euh imposer l'austérilité immédiatement,
revenir très rapidement à à au statut
coxenté. Erreur qu'on a évité pendant la
crise du Covid.
Donc on a eu hélicoptère B ben B ben ben
en hélicoptère qui distribuait
directement pour que la crise de
liquidité interbanciaire ne paralyse pas
tout le système. Est-ce que maintenant
le fait que en 2011, en 2015, en 2016,
en 2017,
le fait parce que 2008, il y a eu ça
mais ça a continué d'injecter,
d'injecter, d'injecter, d'injecter pour
éviter de replonger. Est-ce que
maintenant toutes ces liquidités
injectées par les banques centrales,
c'est une des grosses causes de
l'inflation
qu'on est en train de vivre avant la
guerre d'Ukraine ?
Alors là, à nouveau, moi j'ai pas la
réponse de cette question euh et je ne
pense pas qu' je pense pas qu'il y a un
consensus sur la réponse à cette
question. Alors moi, je ne sais pas,
honnêtement, je sais pas. Je pense qu'on
se pose encore euh on se pose encore les
les euh les la question de la des
raisons fondamentales de cette de de
l'inflation. Les économistes l'ont pas
vu venir, enfin très peu. Il y a que il
y a très peu d'économistes qui l'ont vu
venir. Euh donc et
quels sont les économistes qui l'ont vu
venir ?
Summers. La rue Summers c'est c'est il
en a on est très fier.
Rubini aussi non ?
Ouais. Obin il un petit peu une montre
arrêtée. Il prédit toujours, il pense
toujours qu'il y a une crise ou un
désastre. Donc de temps en temps, il y
en a. C'est trop facile.
C'est c'est trop facile. Euh
il s'est bien positionné en contraré à
un moment. Non. Bon passons.
Donc cette inflation qu'on vit en ce
moment, est-ce que nos gouvernements
avec l'augmentation des taux, ils sont
en train de nous faire un choc volqueur
de derrière les fagot ?
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'un choc Volker ?
Euh, vous explique vous expliquerez
mieux que moi. Je suis pas prix Nobel
d'économie, donc je vous laisse la
parole. Oui, mais moi je fais pas de
macroéconomie. Le risque avec un avec
une augmentation des taux d'intérêt, le
risque domestique, on va parler du
risque domestique puis du risque
international parce que le risque
international m'intéresse plus en fait.
le risque domestique avec une
augmentation des taux d'intérêt qui est
trop forte, c'est ce que les banques
centrales essayent de ce que les banques
centrales essaie de de de naviguer et
c'est c'est leur mandat
euh c'est un arbitrage entre l'inflation
et l'activité économique et en
particulier le chômage. Et c'est
littéralement leur mandat d'essayer de
trouver que l'inflation au moins soit
pas dans une dynamique où elle
s'accélère.
Euh et que en même temps il y a pas trop
de gens au chômage mais c'est difficile.
Ch Walker, je crois que c'était pas ça
du tout. Non, dans mon idée.
Euh non, mais je sais pas en fait de
quoi à quoi vous faites référence avec
le chocol
un banquier central mais je sais pas
exactement à quoi vous faites référence
quand vous faites parler d'un du choler.
Si mes souvenirs sont bons, c'est on
crée du chômage comme ça ça tue
l'inflation. Les gens peuvent plus
acheter.
Oui. Donc donc c'est ça c'est ça le le
mais c'est ça c'est ça le tradeoff.
C'est exactement ça. Donc on parle bien
de la même chose. C'est l'arbitrage.
C'est-à-dire on dit euh l'inflation.
Pourquoi il y a de l'inflation ? Enfin
en gros euh euh
il y a de l'inflation parce que il y a
euh enfin quand il y a de l'inflation,
il y a les salaires qui augmentent, les
prix qui augmentent. Il y a énormément
de demandes de pour
en France, il y a pas les salaires qui
augmentent hein.
Il y a bah les salaires augmentent moins
que les prix. Mais la le
il y a les il y a il y a beaucoup de
demandes pour pas trop de bien. Donc il
y a beaucoup d'activités, il y a il y a
une forte activité économique. Les ça
crée par exemple aux États-Unis
une activité où où il y a quasiment il y
a très très peu de chômage. Il y a une
activité économique en en en forte
qu'on peut dire de de en forte chauffe
disons.
Et ça crée de la pression sur les prix
et sur les salaires parce que ben sur
les salaires parce que les gens qui
veulent recruter et se disent on va
faire augmenter on fait on obligé de
faire augmenter les salaires pour faire
venir les gens sur les prix parce que
les gens sont mieux payés donc et en
plus ils ont ils avaient à la fin du
Covid ils avaient une forte épargne
parce qu'ils avaient pas consommé depuis
longtemps. Donc ils se disent je vais
acheter plus de choses donc je suis prêt
à payer plus cher pour mes billets
d'avion et cetera. Donc ça,
indépendamment de ce qui s'est passé en
Ukraine, indépendamment même des
problèmes de des problèmes de
d'approvisionnement
de de chaînes de de chaînes de valeur.
Donc l'arbitrage que fait les banques
centrales, c'est de dire "Oui, si je je
fais augmenter les taux d'intérêt, il va
y avoir moins d'activité, moins de
construction, moins d'investissement,
donc moins d'emploi, donc moins de
demandes pour des des pour pour des pour
des employés, plus de chômage, ça fait
baisser les salaires, ça fait baisser la
demande, donc ça fait baisser les prix
et ça fait baisser l'inflation."
Donc c'est ça le
l'homme dans tout ça, est-ce que le
banquier central il réfléchit un peu ?
Ah ben c'est une bonne question. Euh euh
il y a deux euh il y a qui peut se poser
à deux niveaux. D'abord, au niveau euh
national, on peut se dire "Oui, en gros,
le banquier central, il essae de il se
dit que l'inflation n'est pas bonne pour
les gens et et donc il se dit bon, j'ai
deux entre mes deux mots, le chômage des
salaires faibles et une inflation trop
forte, je suis obligée de d'équilibrer."
Donc de son du point de vue du mandat de
la banque centrale euh les choses sont
euh c'est un mal contre un mal. On peut
pas dire qu'il fait pas attention à
l'homme ou à la femme par rapport à à
Mais la question que j'ai posé justement
quand on j'ai posé à mes collègues
macroéconomiques, à macroéconomiste
quand on commençait à beaucoup parler
d'inflation mais en fait l'inflation
pourquoi c'est un problème en tant que
tel ? Pourquoi ? Et en fait la réponse
est pas évidente.
C'est pas c'est clair que les
pasinflation c'est pas pratique hein.
C'est s'il faut des des des valises de
billets pour aller payer euh pour aller
acheter sa baguette. les les économies
finissent par s'effondrer. C'est vrai
aussi que l'inflation
touche plus les gens qui ont des revues
des revenus fixe qui peuvent être les
retraités, les gens qui vivent de
d'allocation sociale et cetera si c'est
pas indexé sur sur les salaires. Mais à
part ça, une inflation modérée euh les
pourquoi c'est vraiment un problème pour
l'économie, c'est pas entièrement clair.
Enfin, il y a une espèce de consensus
que c'est pas une bonne chose pour que
c'est pas une bonne chose pour
l'économie. Donc du point de vue des
États-Unis, bah le le blanquier central
il il équilibre entre ces deux ces deux
problèmes. Par contre, là où en tant que
économiste du développement,
je j'ai une vision qui peut être un peu
différente, c'est de dire "Oui, c'est
bien sympathique, mais dans le mandat du
banquier central, il y a pas la personne
qui habite euh au Sri Lanka ou la
personne qui habite en Zambie. Parce que
ce qui se passe quand on augmente les
taux d'intérêt aux États-Unis, c'est que
le remboursement, les frais de
remboursement de la dette pour les
gouvernements qui sont endettés
augmentent. Le cours du dollar augmente
à cause de l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt aux États-Unis qui fait encore
plus augmenter
le le coût du remboursement de la dette
dans les pays dont la dette est en
général dénominée en dollar. Et du coup
ça ça et le le le résultat là où on en
est aujourd'hui, c'est que il y a
plusieurs pays qui sont en en crise de
dette. Donc par exemple en juin, on a
fini par faire un accord avec pour la
Zambie qui était dans une crise de
dette. Il y a d'autres pays qui sont et
il y a il y a d'après le FMI, je crois
que c'est quasiment 60 pays qui sont
soit en déjà en crise de dette, soit
proche de l'être. Et quand un pays euh
pauvre est fait face à une crise
d'endettement, ça veut dire qu'il est
obligé de serrer ses budgets à fond et
ça ça touche directement les gens. Il y
a plus de tradeoff. Euh il y a touche
directement les gens. Ils peuvent plus
faire l'avocat du diable.
Il pardon.
Je peux me faire l'avocat du diable ?
Allez-y.
Moi, je vais vous dire, je me mets à la
position du pays riche qui produit son
dollar et qui a la monnaie mondiale.
Mais c'est vachement bien. Le pays
pauvre qui a sa dette en dollar qui peut
plus rembourser. Moi, j'envoie mon
assassin économique. Vous connaissez
assassin économique comme terme ?
Non.
Economic Hitman.
Vous connaissez ça ?
Non.
Je l'envoie, je lui dis "Bon, c'est pas
grave, tu peux pas payer. On va te
l'étaler avec un tout petit. Mais par
contre, tes matières premières, moi je
vais t'envoyer mes entreprises, tu vas
lui vendre pas cher. Je vous vois
d'autres ligés de la tête. Je vais vous
tu vas vendre pas cher tes matières
premières et tu vas te taire. Et si
on a un leader sur place qui dit "Bon
écoute, tu es bien gentil mais ce sera
non."
Ah, il y a un accident
et ou ou sinon il se fait virer. Oh bah
ou s'il est trop fort ou si son peuple
fait corps, on trouve un prétexte pour
envoyer l'armée.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça ?
Je pense que ça a été
que j'ai fait un bon avocat du diable.
Oui, je pense que je pense que c'est
plus peut-être que ça a été vrai à une
époque. Je pense que ça ne l'est pas.
directement maintenant. Euh je pense que
maintenant honnêtement c'est juste un un
un effet secondaire.
Les crises d'endettement sont un effet
secondaire pas forcément bien anticipé
euh des politi de politiques économiques
que ce soit celle de la Banque centrale
européenne ou celle de la banque du 13
de la Banque centrale aux États-Unis.
C'est justement c'est juste pas dans
leur mandat de se préoccuper de ce qui
se passe au Sri Lanka ou en Zambie ou au
Ghana. Euh là où on a un problème
supplémentaire aujourd'hui, c'est la
Chine. Parce que dans ces conditions,
dans ces conditions de crise
d'endettement, ce qui se passait
traditionnellement, c'est que le FMI
envoyé une équipe sur le terrain,
essayer de et et négocier un accord avec
le pays sur comme vous le disiez là, sur
les taux de remboursement, mais aussi
euh de faire accepter Oui. Donc ça
c'était le disons de faire accepter sa
vue, sa vision de l'économie de
l'économie de marché telle qu'elle
devrait se faire. Euh mais aussi en même
temps de persuader, enfin de forcer à
accepter soit les gouvernements, soit
les banques étrangères qui avaient prêté
à ces pays de prendre ce qu'on appelle
une haircut, c'est-à-dire de perdre une
partie de leur capital dans l'affaire.
Donc la renégociation se produisait avec
euh des pertes euh du côté des des
créanciers. Alors aujourd'hui des
créanciers qui qui détenait des dettes
juniors et des dettes seniores.
Voilà. Alors il devait s'arranger euh et
euh tout le monde
expliquer qui est junior et qui est
senior.
Ben ça dépend des ça dépend des ça
dépend des des types d'emprunt. Donc,
mais les seniors, c'est ceux qui sont
censés être remboursés en premier et les
juniors, c'est ceux qui viennent après.
Mais quand on est dans un cadre de
remboursement de de dette, de
restructuration de de dette, tout le
monde traditionnellement hein, tout le
monde faisait un effort, gouvernement
entre banques et cetera. Peut-être que
l'effort était pas le même pour tout le
monde et que les juniors faisaient un
gros effort où perditz tout ce qu'ils
avaient en tête et les seniors faisaient
un effort plus petit. Mais aujourd'hui,
les choses ont changé à cause de la
Chine parce que la Chine il y a beaucoup
de de banques en soit disant c'est des
banques privées, donc c'est pas le
gouvernement,
c'est des banques indépendantes. Mais
enfin en Chine, les choses sont un peu
euh euh
flou, disons, entre ce qui est le
gouvernement et pas le gouvernement.
Elles refusent euh de négocier dans la
plupart des enfin elles ont refusé
pendant des mois et des mois et des mois
de refuser par exemple dans le cas du
Sri Lanka. Alors, c'est eux, c'est les
Chinois qui avaient énormément de ils
avaient le le Sri Lanka avait avait fait
de grosses dettes euh vis-à-vis de la
Chine pour financer en particulier des
infrastructures pour le tourisme. Puis
le Covid est intervenu, ils ont des
magnifiques routes les Sri Lanka
magnifiques. Puis le Covid est
intervenu, les touristes sont plus
venus, les les les ressources sont plus
rentrées. Le Sri Lanka était dans
l'incapacité absolue de payer et le mais
les Chinois voulaient pas négocier. Du
coup, le Sri Lanka est entré dans une
crise politique terrible qui était une
conséquence directe.
Qui c'est qui est au politique qui est à
la tête du du Sri Lanka en ce moment ?
Ah, c'est une bonne question parce que
c'est
la droite, la droite droite ou la droite
droite droite dur ou c'est la gauche ou
le centre ? des chemises,
c'est pas très Je sais pas si on peut
les placer sur un axe
politique. C'est oui, c'est plutôt c'est
c'est nationaliste mais c'est surtout un
bazar incroyable parce que personne
n'est très puissant puisque justement
pendant qu'il y a eu la pendant que
qu'il y avait cette crise de la dette a
conduit à une crise politique forte qui
fait que les gens qui étaient au pouvoir
se sont fait renverser. Il y avait deux
frères qui qui contrôlaient un peu toute
l'affaire. Bref, euh donc c'est le le
pour l'instant le Sri Lanka, c'est juste
une espèce de de crise politique pas
encore pas encore résolu.
Ça va être un poste avancé devant
l'Inde, c'est ça ?
Euh qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par
poste avant ?
Si si la Chine met la main sur le Sri
Lanka par de la dette, ils vont pouvoir
demander de stationner des bases
militaires.
Les États-Unis ont pas fait ça à un
moment avec d'autres pays.
Je sais pas si euh
négocier le vote à l'ONU.
Je sais pas si c'est l'objectif de la
Chine de mettre des bases militaires au
Sri Lanka. Je je sais pas.
Je pense que personne ne sait.
On en parlera peut-être bientôt. Je vous
ai coupé dans votre développement les
dettes, l'épongement du moins le
mécanisme
d'éponge de dette
arrive 2017.
Comment on est sûr que le marché est
stabilisé, pas stabilisé là ? Qu'est-ce
qui se passe en ce moment en 2023 sur
les marchés financiers, sur les dettes ?
La dette américaine explose, la dette
européenne explose, la dette française
explose, l'inflation explose. Est-ce
qu'il y a à votre avis
un petit
comment formuler ça ? Excusez-moi.
Est-ce qu'on va se tieriser
en Europe ?
Est-ce qu'on va s'appauvrir ? Est-ce
qu'on va voir réémerger
2000 étudiants avant 2000 enfants avant
la rentrée des classes qui vivent à la
rue ? Des étudiants qui sont en grande
privation alimentaire ? Je crois que
c'est 20 de tête, je demande à me faire
fa checker euh une vingtaine de % de
d'étudiants en grande privation
alimentaire, crise du logement,
prostitution des jeunes étudiantes pour
essayer de manger à gauche et à droite.
Est-ce qu'on est en train de se
précariser comme ce que vous pouvez
connaître sur le terrain dans des pays
du tir monde ?
Je pense qu'il faut pas faire de trop de
raccourci entre la dette enfants à la
rue. avec l'inflation peut-être
euh ou même l'inflation parce que euh
je pense que les enfants à la rue ça
correspond plus à euh
une politique de santé
une décision politique, c'est-à-dire je
pense que les gens pas de santé
publique, une politique de de une
politique de solidarité et de et de et
une politique de logement, tout le monde
peut
même dans une économie riche et la
France est une économie riche.
Qu'est-ce qui vous permet de dire ça ?
Bah simplement si on peut regarder notre
PIB par tête en comparaison avec le avec
le le reste du monde ou même en
comparaison
François Fillant dit je suis à la tête
d'un état en faillite.
Il y a il faut pas mélanger les torchons
les serviettes. Euh il y a la question
de l'économie française. Est-ce que
l'économie française est une économie
riche ?
Et la réponse est oui, on produit
beaucoup. Il y a
det
non, on va revenir à la dette d'abord.
On va dire d'abord le l'économie,
l'ensemble de l'économie. Oubliez le
gouvernement pendant un moment. L'emble,
je peux je peux vous couper, je suis un
peu curieux, c'est pas tous les jours.
Le dernier prix Nobel d'économie qu'on a
reçu, c'était il y a 2 3 ans.
Combien de points de PIB
pour combien d'euros injectés en dette ?
Est-ce qu'on a une croissance de
richesse à crédit ?
ou je vous laisse développer
euh je crois pas de PIB pour combien
d'euros de dette ?
C'està-dire en France, quel est le ratio
de la dette par rapport au PIB ? Alors
là, vos vos auditeurs vos auditeurs vont
sûrement me fast checker. Vos auditeurs
et auditrices vont sûrement me fast
checker. Mais
euh
à la louche, ça pourrait être au moins
100 % je pense. Euh mais
à nouveau, on peut pas on peut pas juste
comparer l'un à l'autre en disant "Ah
bah je prends mon PIB, j'enlève la
dette. Donc si j'ai 100 % de du PIB qui
est de la dette, c'est zéro. Mon PIB
c'est zéro. C'est pas ça se compare pas
comme ça le
dans les économistes mais chez les chefs
d'entreprise ça se compare comme ça
hein.
Ah oui mais les entreprises et les
gouvernements, c'est pas du tout la même
chose. Euh le le PIB c'est ce qui est
produit dans notre pays enfin l'ensemble
de de de la valeur qui est créée et il y
a beaucoup de valeur qui est créée. Euh
il y a donc dans un pays qui est riche
comme ça, il absolument aucun doute que
si c'était notre priorité, tous les
enfants pourraient être logés.
D'ailleurs, par exemple, pendant le
Covid
au Angleterre, au Royaume-Uni à Londres,
ils sont ils ont plus voulu qu'il y ait
de gens à la rue. Il y avait plus de
gens à la rue. C'est tout à fait. Et là,
si demain on disait le le
ministre de la ville, lisez le rapport
ou il faudrait peut-être qu' qu'il
demande des sous au ministre des
finances, lisez le rapport de l'UNICEF.
Je crois que c'est l'UNICEF hein qui a
qui a fait ce rapport sur les 2000
enfants et nous disait
euh et disait c'est pas possible, on va
leur trouver des solutions de logement,
ce serait possible, ce serait
immédiatement possible. Donc c'est pas
une question chose pour la fin dans le
monde.
Non, la fin dans le monde c'est plus
difficile là parce que là c'est possible
la fin dans le monde c'est à un certain
un certain niveau, c'est pareil mais à
un certain niveau c'est différent.
un un niveau abstrait, c'est pareil dans
le sens où il y a largement largement
largement assez de ressources en
nourriture dans le monde pour que
personne n'ait faim et que
[Musique]
on il faut la raison pour laquelle il y
a des gens qui ont faim et il y a
beaucoup de de gens qui ont faim,
beaucoup trop, c'est parce que c'est des
problèmes de distribution. Il y a trop
de nourriture à certains endroits et il
y en a pas assez à d'autres. Donc c'est
un problème humain de de répartition de
la nourriture. On voit des des
manifestations particulièrement
intense de ça avec les le blé ukrainien
et russe qui peut plus aller vers
l'Afrique. Mais de manière plus
générale, quand il y a une famine
quelque part,
le riz indien aussi qui est un petit peu
gardé que le riz indien qui est gardé
alors que c'est pas alors que il y a
assez de enfin il y a un excédent de de
riz en Inde. Torin Tor ou peut-être un
peu plus de Torah mais le mais c'est
c'était vraiment c'était une c'est une
décision plutôt politique d'image que de
s'assurer de la sécurité alimentaire de
l'Inde dire l'Inde d'abord et cetera
mais le le le point et ça c'est à
Martiassen l'a la l'a démontré
brillamment il y a déjà plusieurs
plusieurs décennies les famines il y a
pas de raison qu'il a les familles quand
il y a une famine c'est toujours une
toujours une cause humaine de
désorganisation. Il y a largement assez
de ressources dans le monde pour pour
qu'il y ait pas de famille. Mais
des gens qui vont en prison quand il y a
des gens qui meurent de faim. Alors,
d'abord pour passer de de mais pour
passer de de Donc ça c'est c'est vrai en
général, c'est-à-dire il y a assez de
nourriture dans le monde pour que tout
le monde mange. Mais
euh
il y a il y a beaucoup de mais il y a
des obstacles. Voilà, il y a beaucoup
d'obstacles qui empêchent cette
nourriture de se produire. Ça peut être
un c'est pas une solution miracle qui va
résoudre tout le problème d'un coup.
tandis que dans le cas des enfants qui
sont à la rue, on parle de 2000 enfants
là franchement il y a une solution
miracle pour en France aujourd'hui.
Là c'est vraiment un problème un
problème
relativement bien limité, relativement
étroit et qu'on a montré qu'on pouvait
résoudre si on le souhaitait. Donc c'est
pour ça ces deux
pour les SDF
ces deux sujets
plus âgés
pour les FDF je pense
pour les SDF plus âgés, je pense que
c'est plus compliqué. C'est-à-dire
pareil, à mon avis, il y a dans un pays
comme la France, il y a largement assez
de ressources pour que tout le monde ait
un toit. Mais on sait qu' Mais il va
sûrement mais on sait que pour
s'attaquer au problème de SDF, ça va
être pas, il suffit pas de dire euh de
signer un papier en disant voilà, il y a
les SDF ne sont plus légaux. Maintenant,
tous les SDF vont être vont être logés.
On
il y a différentes situations qui vont
demander différents programmes. Il y a
des politiques qui sont plus eff plus
utiles que d'autres. Il y a des gens qui
disent il faut mettre les gens en
logement d'abord parce que c'est à
partir du logement que euh tout se
découle. C'est l'idée de housing force.
Il y a des gens qui disent non, il faut
d'abord mettre les gens en emploi et
c'est l'emploi qui va découler. Et c'est
là où on on arrive beaucoup plus proche
de ce que moi je fais. C'est-à-dire sur
chacun de ces problèmes, on commence à
regarder beaucoup plus en détail
qu'est-ce qui marche, qu'est-ce qui
marche pas, pourquoi ça marche, pourquoi
ça marche pas. Alors, il se trouve que
sur les SDF, moi j'ai pas c'est pas sur
quelque chose sur lequel j'ai travaillé,
mais c'est parce que je travaille je
travaille surtout dans les pays pauvres,
mais c'est quelque chose par exemple sur
lequel au laboratoire dans le
laboratoire que je dirige, le
laboratoire d'action contre la pauvreté
aux États-Unis, il y a tout un pan de
recherche sur ces questions de de
logement. Ça trouve un peu ou c'est des
chercheurs qui cherchent ?
Ah, ça trouve, ça trouve. C'est
l'avantage de ce qu'on fait nous.
C'est-à-dire par rapport à bon pour
prendre un peu de recul par rapport à il
y avait une autre blague
où quelqu'un voulait qu'on lui donne un
économiste avec un seul bras parce que
les économistes
parce que les économistes il toujours on
the one hand on the other hand.
Donc il disait plus s'il vous plaît
donnez-moi un économiste qui a deux bras
parce que c'est les c'est une expression
anglaise. C'est d'un côté mais de
l'autre. On the one hand on the other
hand. Please, s'il vous plaît,
donnez-moi un économiste à deux bruns.
Alors, ce que je fais moi dans dans mon
travail et ce et tout le réseau que j'ai
que je que j'anime ce mouvement, euh,
c'est de travailler avec des partenaires
de terrain pour résoudre des problèmes
beaucoup plus spécifiques. Par exemple,
euh
les enfants vont à l'école en Inde mais
ils apprennent pas. Ils ils finissent le
CM2, ils savent toujours pas lire.
Voilà, on peut dire voilà un problème
spécifique euh quel qu'est-ce qu'il
pourrait y avoir comme solution ? Et
différentes organisations ou
gouvernement ont des idées diverses et
variées de de solutions. Par exemple, ah
ben on pourrait faire euh on pourrait
mettre des ordinateurs ou on pourrait
avoir plus de manuel scolaire où on
pourrait faire du soutien scolaire.
On peut stabiliser les parents.
On peut stabiliser les parents,
leur mettre un toit sur la tête, leur
donner de la lumière pour qu'ils
puissent étudier.
Exactement. On pourrait Ouais. toutes
ces différentes donc en pratique, vous
prè toute une liste d'interventions
et différents et euh notre travail, ça
consiste à tester euh ces interventions
euh à la avec la même rigueur que les
essais cliniques.
Donc euh donc on fait un essai clinique
pour un
la même rigueur que les agences de
notation avant la crise des subprime
avec beaucoup plus de rigueur que les
agences de notation avant la crise des
subprime en particulier parce que en
nous on n' pas de conflit d'intérêt.
Donc
quand vous avez un nouveau quand vous
avez un nouveau médicament ou un nouveau
vaccin, vous prenez une population par
exemple, on peut prendre l'exemple du
vaccin contre le Covid parce que je
pense que beaucoup beaucoup de de des
auditeurs auront suivi un petit peu
comment s'est passé le
fait pas de parallèle avec les vaccins à
l'Afrique et les les classes pauvres
parce on reviendra après. Mais le les
vaccins contre le Covid pour tester le
vaccin contre le Covid, le vaccin Piser,
c'était un échantillon de 50 50000
personnes. Euh 50000 personnes, la
moitié reçoivent le vaccin, l'autre
moitié choisie au hasard reçoit un
placebo et ensuite ils les ont suivi
pendant plusieurs semaines pour voir
s'il dével s'il devenait malade du Covid
et
s'ils avaient des effets secondaires.
Si s'ils avaient des effets secondaires
s'il mourent du Covid, s'ils étaient
sérieusement malades et cetera. Et c'est
comme ça qu'au bout de plusieurs
semaines, on a pu voir que les taux
d'être très sérieusement malades du
Covid une fois qu'on était vacciné était
beaucoup plus faible que si on était pas
vacciné. Ce qui nous donne les
l'efficacité euh ce qui nous ce qui nous
permet de conclure que le vaccin est
efficace. Euh donc ça depuis en médecine
c'est c'est cette idée de décès clinique
a révolutionné la la médecine au 20e
siècle.
Euh nous on applique exactement la même
méthode mais pour
50000 personnes,
souvent plus euh parce que les les
échantillons avec lesquels on travaille
pour quand c'est la vie réelle, c'est
plus compliqué que la médecine. Il y a
beaucoup de choses qui interviennent et
cetera. Donc
c'est compliqué.
La médecine c'est compliqué mais les
la vie voilà ma maman me l'a dit. la
médecine, c'est compliqué et chaque
personne est est au-delà d'une
statistique comme le savent les médecins
praticiens, mais quand même c'est moins
compliqué que la vie sociale et
économique des des gens où il se passe
tout un tas de trucs qui euh qui fait
que même si on a choisi un échantillon
au hasard, faut que les échantillons
soient suffisamment larges pour que
toutes les les bricoles qui peuvent
arriver à chaque personne dans un groupe
ou dans l'autre s'annule statistiquement
pour que la différence entre le groupe
qui reçoit telle intervention et le
groupe qui qui en reçoit une autre soit
puisse être attribué à à l'intervention.
Donc pour donner un exemple par exemple
sur le soutien scolaire, euh c'était une
des premières évaluations auxquelles
j'ai participé avec l'organisation
Pratam en Inde.
Euh c'était dans deux villes à Bombé et
à Baroda.
Mumbai
Mumbai maintenant et Vadodara en fait
au Gjrat. et ils avaient euh pris euh
200 écoles dans chaque dans chaque
endroit et euh couper les écoles
les ont séparé pardon c'était 100 écoles
dans chaque endroit et il les avait dit
moitié la dans la moitié des écoles le
programme de soutien scolaire était
donné pour la la classe 3 c'estàdire
l'équivalent du CE2 et pour l'autre
moitié pour la classe 4 équivalent du
CM1.
Ils ont des uniformes là-bas. Ils ont
des uniformes. Ouais. Et ensuite, on
peut comparer au bout de au bout de d'un
an euh les performances euh de grat de
de classe 4, là où il y a pas le
programme, avec classe 4 où il y a le
programme et euh c'est même chose pour
la classe 3. Et comme ça, on a pu voir
il y a comme on les a comme les les
écoles où le programme a été en classe 3
ou en classe 4 et ont été choisis au
hasard, on sait qu'il y a pas de
différence
systématique entre les deux groupes que
si on envoie une à la fin
d'apprentissage, c'est l'effet du
programme. Là en l'occurrence, il y
avait un effet positif.
Il y a des gens qui vous critiquent sur
votre méthodologie d'étude ou pas ? Oui,
oui, oui, bien sûr.
Il y a toute une liste de critiques
potentielles. Euh
les trois principales
euh peut-être la la la première ou la la
plus répandue, c'est celle auxquelle
vous avez fait allusion. Euh euh
je fais pas d'allusion ici
mais vous avez quand même fait allusion
à une euh
au départ c'est de dire oui tout ça
c'est c'est les vous avez le nez dans
guidon le nez dans guidon euh ou
sur des interventions spécifiques. Mais
euh qu'est-ce que ça nous dit sur la
macroéconomie, le capitalisme
euh l'écructurel de la pauvreté et
cetera. Donc
je peux vous ouvrir une parenthèse et
vous déconcentrer ? Oui.
Est-ce que on laisse des gens dans la
rue, on laisse des gens avoir faim, un
peu comme la religion catholique nous
fait croire que si tu n'es pas gentil,
tu vas aller en enfer ? Est-ce que
derrière toute grande fortune, il y a du
sang de pauvre ? Et pour que les pauvres
ou les gens qui travaillent comme des
esclaves se taisent, on lui dit "Sois
heureux de ce que tu as parce que sinon
tu vas finir sur le trottoir."
Ah,
la première partie de ce que vous avez
dit, je
serais assez d'accord, c'est-à-dire
le le système de protection sociale euh
hérité de l'air victorienne au
Royaume-Uni
et clairement
euh un but de de cette euh de cette
vision chrétienne de la du péché de de
de Paris et les Victoriens qui
construisent des maisons pour les
pauvres qui ressemblent plus à des
prisons quasiment sont euh assez clair
là-dessus
et et on voit cette arc
euh où euh il y a le péché de Paris Et
on a peur qu'en étant trop généreux avec
les pauvres et trop généreux avec le
système de protection sociale, on les
rend paresseux et que ce serait pas leur
faire un service. Ça, je crois que c'est
quelque chose qu'on retrouve bah des
victoriens jusqu'à aujourd'hui, que ce
soit dans les pays riches ou dans les ou
dans les dans les pays pauvres. le
système de protection sociale dans les
pays pauvres, il a la même il a la même
euh
le même arrière-goût comme de contrôle
social et de surtout faut pas trop en
faire parce qu'il faut pas que la
pauvreté soit soit confortable.
Et euh ce qui est intéressant, c'est que
cette idée, elle est vraiment
extrêmement je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens qui les croient très
profondément. On avait fait un sondage
d'ailleurs pour un pour l'introduction
d'un livre qu'on avait écrit avec Abidj
Bannergy en demandant aux gens est-ce
que vous pensez est-ce que si le système
de d'assurance santé c'était aux
États-Unis ? Donc est-ce que si vous
pensez que le système d'assurance santé
était euh pas conditionnel au travail,
vous travailleriez moins ?
Euh et la plupart des gens ils disent
non, il disent non moi je travaillerai
de toute façon je travaillerai.
Et ensuite on donc ça c'est la moitié
des gens posé cette question là. L'autre
moitié des gens on leur a posé la
question est-ce que si le système de
d'assurance santé n'était pas
conditionnel au travail les les gens en
général travailleraient moins et là ils
nous disent tous ah oui oui les gens en
général ils travailleraient moins parce
que ça les rendrait paresseux et cetera.
Donc on a c'est quelque chose qui est
très profond chez euh chez les humains,
cette euh cette peur que les autres tir
avant tirent près davantage de moi,
deviennent paresseux et cetera.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que
c'est pas vrai. C'est-à-dire maintenant,
on a depuis euh au moins 10 ans des une
accumulation de recherche qui montre
quand que quand on est plus généreux
avec les pauvres, euh ça les décourage
pas de travailler. Quand on est plus
généreux dans nos allocations sociales,
ça les décourage pas de travailler.
Ça coûte moins cher infiné. Et parfois
ça les ça les ça coûte moins cher une
fin parce qu'on a pas des gens qui
s'enfoncent dans dans la pauvreté et
parfois ça même les encourage à
travailler pour en particulier pour les
extrêmement pauvres.
Euh il y a un programme euh qui a été au
départ inventé par l'organisation Brac
au Bangladesh qui est de dire on va leur
donner un don, pas un prêt. On va
prendre on va identifier les plus
pauvres des pauvres, les gens qui euh
dont on pourrait penser que c'est
vraiment de leur faute, hein. Il y a de
l'alcoolisme dans le chez le mari par
exemple ou
chez la femme
euh ou ou chez la femme, enf général au
Bangladesh, c'est pas tellement les
femmes mais euh et on va identifier les
plus pauvres des pauvres dans les
villages et on va leur donner euh de
quoi démarrer euh leur petite activité.
Donc ça peut être deux vaches ou quatre
chèvres ou une machine à coudre ou
un don, pas un microcrédit,
un don
très important.
Et non seulement leur fait ce don d'une
de cette de ce démarrage d'activité,
mais en plus
on va les soutenir pendant 18 mois pour
qu'ils soient pas tentés de liquider ce
don immédiatement parce qu'ils ont
besoin de l'argent tout de suite. Donc
ils reçoivent un petit un petit
transfert financier de quoi s'acheter à
manger pendant 6 mois à peu près. Et
puis après pendant 18 mois, ils sont
aidés. Si c'est des vaches, elles sont
vaccinées, on leur apprend comment s'en
occuper, on leur euh on leur montre si
les si la femme sait pas écrire, on lui
apprend les rudiment de l'écriture à
signer. On si elle a un petit euh
business, on lui montre comment prendre
le bus pour aller en ville, pour vendre
ses ses choses et cetera.
Euh donc c'est un programme qui coûte
cher euh parce que il y a les deux
vaches plus à peu près un doublement de
de en terme de salaire et cetera. Mais
il a été évalué d'abord au Bangladesh
puis dans sep autres pays. Et ce qu'on a
montré c'est que bien qu'il coûte cher,
il coûte il il se rembourse au bout de 3
4 ans, pas en terme financier puisque
c'est un don, mais en terme de
d'augmentation de la consommation et des
revenus de de ses familles qui sortent
durablement de la pauvreté.
euh en commençant par bien s'occuper de
leur de leur assette, puis après en
changeant, en général, ils changent de
business, ils prennent un business moins
au départ ils font quelque chose très
proche d'eux comme des ils préfèrent les
vaches par exemple puis après il euh ils
investissent plus tôt dans dans une dans
une petite boutique et puis après c'est
les enfants qui partent et qui migrent
en Inde. On les a maintenant suivis
pendant plus de de 10 ans après avoir
reçu le premier transfert. Et un
décrochage, ça a été évalué
expérimentalement. Donc on peut comparer
notre traitement avec notre groupe de
contrôle initial. Il y a un décrochage
des euh des familles où les familles
traitées sont de moins en moins pauvre
par rapport aux familles qui ont pas été
aidées.
Donc de recevoir euh cette aide en fait
ça fait sortir les gens durablement de
la pauvreté. Et dans dans ces
conditions, dans une autre expérience au
Ghana qui est avec le le même type de
programme, euh ce que les chercheurs
avaient fait après, c'est de proposer
aux femmes la possibilité de travailler
pour coudre des sacs.
Euh et il l'avait proposé à tout le
monde, au traitement et au contrôle. Et
ce qu'il se rendent compte, c'est ceux
qui ont reçu le le don et qui donc ont
un petit business à eux, ils ont plus de
chance d'accepter de travailler pour les
sacs, ils sont plus productifs sur les
sacs, ils gagnent plus d'argent sur les
sacs. Donc l'effet, c'est exactement
l'inverse de celui dont on avait peur
les victoriens et dont vous parlez avec
la religion catholique. C'est-à-dire
vous êtes protestante vous ?
Oui.
Vous avez un ami imaginaire ?
Est-ce que j'ai un ami imaginaire ?
Vous croyez en Dieu ?
Ah non.
Mais je suis j'ai été élevé dans le
protestantisme.
Euh donc j'en ai sûrement des
Elles sont jolies les églises
protestantes.
Des restes, elles sont sobres. La
musique sont bien sonorisé.
La musique est magnifique.
Vous avez été à Hambourg ?
Euh je suis jamais allé à Hambourg
mais j'adore la musique de bac. Donc
j'ai une très certainement toute une
éthique protestante au fond de moi. Mais
cela dit à malgré celause
peut-être malgré parce que c'est je
pense que cette espèce de peur de la
paresse, on le retrouve aussi bien dans
le catholicisme que dans le
protestantisme. Mais
vous az étudié Luther ?
Euh bah non non, j'ai pas fait de
théologie. Puis en plus chez nous, on
est plutôt calviniste.
Donc mais euh euh
le plus important pour moi et ça ça
indépendamment de de d'où je d'où je
viens euh c'est euh
et ça ça m'a été enseigné par le
terrain.
de dire c'est c'est d'essayer de ne pas
apporter de
prénotion
avant de de faire une étude.
C'est-à-dire j'ai vu trop de situations
où nos intuitions sont fausses. Mes
intuitions sont fausses. Les intuitions
des gens qui travaillent sur le terrain
qui sont parfaitement plein de bonnes
volontés sont fausses. Les intuitions,
cette intuition qui est tellement
partagée que si on on n'est plus
généreux, ça ça les rend généreux, ça
rend les gens paresseux. cette intuition
est fausse. Donc ce que j'essaie de
faire indépendamment du bagage que je
suis sûre j'amène dans mes études dans
dans dans mes recherches, dans mon
travail sur le terrain, c'est vraiment
d'essayer de le laisser de côté et de
laisser les données parler. Et c'est ça
la beauté de de l'évaluation aléatoire,
c'est que
d'accord, tu as une intuition, on
essaye, on verra ce que ça donne. Et là,
c'est vraiment le test direct. C'était
quand on donne aux gens un un ils ont
déjà un asset, ils sont plus riches, ils
ont déjà du travail pour rien que pour
s'occuper de cette assette, ils sont
quand même ils travaillent quand même
plus que ceux à qui qu'on a pas aidé.
Donc ça et ça va dans l'autre sens, ça
va dans le sens opposé.
Donc et dans toutes les études qui ont
été faites, que ce soit dans les pays
pauvres ou dans les pays riches euh où
les euh où des gens ont bénéficié d'un
revenu qui était pas conditionnel à la
participation au marché du travail, on
trouve soit aucun effet sur la
participation au marché du travail, soit
un effet qui va dans le sens opposé ou
au contraire ça aide à remettre le pied
à l'étrayer des gens qui se mettent à
travailler davantage.
Comment vous jugez la politique
économique de Bruno Leire ?
Euh
c'est
vous avez vous avez fait un petit livre,
on va en parler après, mais faudrait
l'envoyer au ministère de Bruno.
C'est dur de juger. Enfin, c'est c'est
pareil. C'est pour moi, c'est un petit
peu
Vous avez la citoyenneté américaine,
vous pouvez prendre l'avion.
Ah non. Oui. Ou il y a pas de risque.
C'est pas une question, c'est un peu une
question.
Vous payez vos impôts aux États-Unis ou
en France ?
Je paye mes impôts aux États-Unis et en
France.
Vous gagnez combien ?
Ah, je partage pas mon mon revenu, mais
je gagne de l'argent en France sur
lequel je paye un impôt en France et je
paye je gagne de l'argent aux États-Unis
sur lequel je paye des impôt
partagez pas votre revenue. Mais
je sais pas, ça se fait pas du tout euh
aux États-Unis, ça se fait pas du tout.
Ouais. En France ?
Oui, mais comme
Non, partage pas Brun.
Donc Bruno Lemire.
Bruno Lemè. à une question qui est
difficile, c'est une question à laquelle
est difficile de répondre parce que la
politique économique de Bruno Lemer,
c'est un ensemble de choses. Quoi qu'il
en coûte,
quoi qu'il en coûte euh quoi qu'il en
coûte, mais pas avec les pauvres. quoi
qu'il en coûte, bah non, si on prend par
exemple ce qui s'est passé pendant le
Covid euh que ce soit aux États-Unis ou
en France, je pense que la réaction
immédiate au Covid qui était le quoi
qu'il en coûte, qui était en fait une
une réponse à ce qui n'avait pas été
fait pendant la crise de 2008 euh était
euh euh
a été bénéfique. C'estàd ce qu'on voit
en ce qu'on voit par exemple au ni en
France ni aux États-Unis une
augmentation de la pauvreté. Alors que
dans les pays pauvres où il y a pas eu
de euh dans les pays pauvres où
c'est quoi vos chiffres ?
Bah aux États-Unis, on voit même une
légère pendant la toute la période de
Covid, on voit même en terme de taux de
pauvreté une légère diminution euh de la
pauvreté parce que les pertes de revenus
ont été compensées par des transferts
sociaux pendant la période de Covid.
Après
la même chose avec les entreprises sous
perfusion
après voilà
les entreprises zombies c'est ça ? Bah
les il y a eu il y a eu des excès dans
la dans dans la manière dont le je pense
que la manière dont ça a été don dont
les aides COVID ont été faites aux
États-Unis était en fait moins bonne que
que en France que en Europe. Pas
seulement en France. C'est dire en
Europe, en général, ce qu'on a fait,
c'est qu'on a euh on a euh payé les
entreprises pour qu'ils continuent à
payer leurs employés euh euh
pendant la quand étit obligé de de
rester à la maison avant de pouvoir
retravailler. t dit qu'aux États-Unis,
ils ont laissé les entreprises
s'arrê renvoyer les gens et ils les ont
compensé sous la forme de sous la forme
de
d'assurance chômage. Et pendant ce
temps, ils ont laissé aux entreprises la
possibilité de de recevoir des prêts à
taux extrêmement bonifiés qui se sont
transformés en don par la suite. Mais
ces procédures étaient suffisamment
compliquées pour que il y a eu bah en
fait les les beaucoup de gens
les gens qui en avaient vraiment besoin
étaient pas capable d'emprunter et
beaucoup de gens qui en avaient
complètement bénéficié du système d'où
les entreprises d'où les entreprises
zombies. Il y a eu des études
d'économistes qui ont été faites après
sur les États-Unis pour montrer qu'il y
a eu énormément de énormément de pertes
dans le dans la manière dont ça a été
administré. Mais le fait de dire "On va
pas laisser les gens
s'effondrer euh pendant la crise du
Covid euh ça nous a permis et à un coût
très important hein, les les économies
euh avant riches euh ont dépensé d'après
le FMI euh à je crois que c'est 27 % de
leur PIB en mesure de soutien fiscal
pendant le Covid.
Les économies les plus pauvres, les pays
les plus pauvres n'ont pas la
possibilité de faire quoi qu'il en côte,
ils auraient bien aimé, mais ils sont
évidemment pas capable d'aller sur les
places financières pour emprunter. On
dépensé les donc les les
2 % de leur PIB en mesure de soutien à
leur population, 2 % d'un PIB beaucoup
plus faible évidemment. Donc du coup
essentiellement n'ont pas pu venir en
aide à leur population pendant le Covid.
euh
à l'époque où au début du Covid quand ça
a été lancé le quoi qu'il en coûte, ça
me j'étais extrêmement en faveur. Je
l'ai dit à ce moment-là, je pense encore
que c'est ce qu'on aurait dû que c'était
une bonne chose à faire dans le sens où
ça a év ça a quand même éviter que les
gens s'enfoncent dans des situations
dans lesquelles il aurait été beaucoup
plus desquelles il aura été beaucoup
plus difficile de de ressortir et qui
euh qui aurait du coup créé ce qu'on a
vu dans les pays pauvres des trappes de
pauvreté indépendamment après la crise
du Covid immédiatement il y a eu la
guerre en Ukraine l'inflation et cetera
ce qui a rendu difficile de repartir
dans les économies les plus pauvres,
mais même sans cela, le fait que les
gens avaient perdu leur business, avait
perdu leur emploi, avait parfois perdu
leur logement et cetera, ça rendait le
redémarrage des économies les plus
pauvres beaucoup plus lent par rapport à
ce qui s'est passé chez nous.
Et l'histoire de la fortune de son
pauvre, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
La fortune de
est-ce que tout est-ce que derrière
toute grande fortune il y a du oubliez
pas. Euh donc ça c'est la deuxème ça
c'est malédiction. Ça d'ailleurs
c'était la deuxième partie de c'était la
deuxième partie de votre question. Donc
la première je suis d'accord sans
réservation.
La deuxième euh
je pense que ça
ça dépend des des périodes dans
l'histoire et ça dépend des pays. Et la
raison pour laquelle ça dépend des
périodes et ça dépend des pays, c'est
que ça dépend de dans quelle mesure les
entreprises sont encadré ou pas dans ce
qu'elles font.
Les la la tendance naturelle d'une
entreprise,
c'est de maximiser ses profits au dépend
de tout le monde des autres. Euh
euh Friedman disait que la
responsabilité d'une entreprise c'était
de maximiser ses profits. Euh ce qui une
des choses qui a rendu les la il disait
la responsabilité sociale des
entreprises, c'est de maximiser leurs
profits. qu'il a une des choses qui a
rendu les économistes très populaires
comme profession
aux États-Unis
euh partout parce qu'il y a cette idée
que les économistes sont juste des euh
des euh des des prophètes pour le
capitalisme parce que quand on a des
économistes comme Fritman qui disent ça,
forcément ça ça
ça
encourage ça ça justifie que les gens
aent cette opinion des économistes alors
que bon c'est pas tout le monde n'est
pas n'a pas la même opinion opinion.
Mais si c'est pas la responsabilité
sociale des entreprises, c'est
certainement leur tendance naturelle,
disons la tendance naturelle d'une
entreprise qui a des actionnaires et
d'un CEO qui a des actionnaires, c'est
de faire le maximum pour euh pour
augmenter son profit au dépend de
ses employés, de ses consommateurs et
cetera,
de l'État
de l'État dans la mesure au maximum
possible. Et donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut c'est pour ça que la la les
entreprises euh n'opèrent pas dans le
vide, elles opèrent dans dans un système
politique et que la nature de système
politique que euh à la fois le le le
euh le les règles explicites mais aussi
les normes euh plus implicites euh ont
une influence sur la réponse à la
question.
Est-ce qu'il y a une intrication entre
le monde industriel et le monde
politique ?
Il y a eu une intrication assez forte.
qu'on trouve qui à nouveau dépend aussi
de d'un pays à l'autre. Mais par exemple
aux États-Unis le
il y a un très fort lobby lobbying des
entreprises. Il y a des des portes
euh en anglais on dit revolving d'or.
C'est dire on entre et on sort par la
même porte.
Chez nous, on dit du pantouflage.
Voilà, chez nous, on dit du pantouflage.
Euh euh mais j'ai l'impression que les
gens pantouflent passent du secteur
public au secteur privé puis il reste.
Aux États-Unis, les gens font euh font
des allers-retours. Euh il y a aussi euh
bah surtout depuis aux États-Unis,
depuis la décision de la Cour suprême de
euh de ne donner aucune
aucune de n'imposer aucune limite au
financement des campagnes
euh au nom de la liberté de la presse
par au financement de campagne par les
entreprises. Du coup, c'est absolument
clair que les entreprises ont un pouvoir
sur la vie démocratique et donc sur les
lois qui est qui est important. Donc il
y a il y a un lien entre les deux.
Euh entre les deux qui limite les
capacités des gouvernements à euh canal
canaliser disons les les
désirs euh d'augmentation de de profit
des entreprises. Donc c'est une c'est
une espèce de de lutte permanente entre
le reste de la société et les
entreprises médiatisé par le
gouvernement. Mais le gouvernement c'est
des gens qui mettent qui sont élus
donc avec plus ou moins d'efficacité
d'une d'un moment à l'autre.
C'est quoi la subordination de vote ?
Euh
je sais pas exactement parce que je vois
pas
pour moi. Je suis le président du
pouvoir d'achat, tout va bien aller et
puis derrière je fais de la dette. Donc
j'achète la la j'achète pratiquement mes
électeurs.
C'est que c'est ce qu'on ce qu'on
appelle
voter pour moi et puis derrière bram la
dette publique explose.
Alors subation de vote c'est ce qu'on
appelle c'est ce qu'on appelle en
anglais vote buying l'achat de D'accord.
Non mais non non, on fait pas du d'assau
chez nous, on fait d'une façon
plus euh
plus classe
euh
le fait de
Oui, je sais pas si de dire ça euh de
dire si en supposant que c'est ça qui se
passe, dire voter pour moi, le pouvoir
d'achat va augmenter, je
vais baisser les impôts.
Je vais baisser les impôts. C'est un peu
le c'est un peu le le
c'est un peu la rangaine que tout le
monde répète. C'est pour ça que c'est
le résultat c'est quoi ?
Bah le résultat
dernières années
le résultat donc vous parliez de de la
dette.
J'ai pas su quel était le pourcentage de
la dette publique par rapport au PIB en
France mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ça
augment qu'il a augmenté qu'il augmente
dette
publique la dette privée. On peut lui
les additionner si vous voulez.
On on peut encore plus les additionner.
Enfin, peut-être pour pour la question
pour la question qui vous occupe, c'est
plutôt la dette publique qui est
importante. C'est
Non non non, on aime bien aussi la dette
privée nous parce que ça permet pas de
la mettre dans la dette publique.
Au final, on se dit sur de très long
terme. C'est ça la différence. Enfin,
c'est une différence entre un une
entreprise et un et un gouvernement.
C'estàdire un gouvernement n'a pas
besoin de balancer son budget toute tout
le temps, ni contrairement à un bon père
de famille ou à une entreprise, un
gouvernement a potentiellement un temps
long devant lui euh qui lui et en
particulier quand sa dote quand sa note
de crédit est bonne a la capacité
d'emprunter justement pour aider les
bons pères et mères de famille à faire
face à une période difficile. C'est quoi
un temps long politique ? Excusez-moi,
je pas
un temps long devant lui, pas
spécialement politique, un temps long
devant lui. Un gouvernement, par
exemple, dans le dans la crise du Covid
euh les gens les individus n'auraient
pas tellement pu aller à la banque et
disaient euh il faudrait que vous me
prêtz de l'argent parce que là euh je
travaille plus. Euh il fallait que le
gouvernement le fasse au nom de ses
citoyens en disant le
Vous pouvez avoir un autre point, un
prisme de lecture sur le gouvernement.
Le gouvernement arrose les entreprises
et ses électeurs parce qu'il a pas été
foutu d'anticiper la mondialisation des
virus, les vecteurs ultra rapides de
virus tels que les avions, les trains et
ainsi de suite. Que bah les masques,
bon, il y a pas de masque que le système
de santé. Oh le système de santé, ça
fait des années qu'on supprime des lits.
Donc bon, on se retrouve à triller les
passants sur les patients sur le le
trottoir. Mais c'est pas de notre faute,
vous comprenez ? Parce que notre
président d'avant et d'avant et d'avant
et d'avant, ils ont fait toujours la
même chose. Donc on arrose tout le monde
parce que sinon,
vous comprenez, si les gens commencent à
dire "Non mais là, vous êtes en train de
trier entre ma mère, mon frère sur le
trottoir devant l'Ostau
en France, qu'est-ce que ça donne ?
coupe de tête. Donc plutôt que il y ait
des gouvernements ultra nationalistes ou
ultra de droite qui récupèrent le truc,
ils ont arrosé tout le monde
drapé dans les tandard de on va saer
tout le monde. Mais derrière où est la
conduite résiliente ?
Non, c'est parant les choses. C'est
parant le le la question de la de la
disons du
économique.
Ouais. La question, c'est la question
que vous posez qui est parfaitement
légitime, c'est-à-dire comment ça se
fait qu'on était pas prêt
à
à à à à quelque chose comme le Covid et
est-ce qu'on sera prêt au prochain ? Et
ça paraît pas du tout clair que ce soit
le cas. Donc qui a une question de
politique, c'est pas juste économique,
de politique de santé, de politique
d'anticipation, de même d'écouter. Donc
une partie, je vais revenir là-dessus.
Je suis euh
je vais revenir là-dessus dans une
seconde, mais ces parents là et voilà
pour toutes ces raisons,
on se on fait face à un choc
à très fort euh celui du Covid par
exemple.
Un individu ne peut pas faire face à ce
choc tout seul. un individu que ce soit
un père de famille, un bon père de
famille ou une mère de famille ou euh un
responsable d'entreprise. le
gouvernement lui quand on est dans un
pays comme la France qui a la chance
d'être un pays riche
et c'est pas vrai si vous êtes au Togo,
vous avez pas la capacité d'aller
emprunter, mais le gouvernement de de la
France peut emprunter euh auprès de ses
citoyens ou auprès du marché pour aider
les gens à faire face à cette crise et
éviter
euh un
un emballement de de c'estd ce qu'on
aurait ce qu'on aurait pu ce au quoi on
aurait été euh
ce au quoi où on aurait été confronté si
on avait pas aidé les gens efficacement
économiquement quand on leur a demandé
de rester chez eux. Euh c'est à au même
phénomène que celui qu'on décrivait sur
les dans les usines de meubles, dans les
villes qui produisaient des meubles.
C'est-à-dire une une dououpe, une un
espèce de cercle vicieux où les gens
consomment moins parce qu'ils perdent
leurs emplois. Du coup, il y a moins les
les les
la demande baisse, la demande pour les
services baisse, tout baisse et cetera
et finalement l'ensemble de l'économie
s'effondre. Et de sortir d'une économie
qui s'effondre, c'est très difficile.
Je peux faire encore l'invoquer du
diable ? Ah ben juste terminons ça
avec plaisir.
Donc le rôle d'un gouvernement, c'est de
d'aider bah c'est un des rôles du
gouvernement pendant une une crise comme
celle du Covid, c'est d'aider les gens à
à c'est de se faire leur leurs banquier
en quelque sorte pour aider les gens à à
passer cette phase. Après, c'est ça,
c'est en principe, c'est conjoncturel,
c'est-à-dire après, ça veut pas dire
qu'on peut avoir en permanence un
déséquilibre entre les les recettes et
les et les dépenses. C'est-à-dire que
quand même sur le long terme ou
peut-être même sur le moyen terme, il
faut équilibrer les dépenses et les et
les recettes. Et le problème avec ce que
vous disiez
le problème politique qu'on rencontre,
c'est que personne ne veut augmenter les
impôts, même sur les plus riches.
les personnes, c'est-à-dire aucun
responsable politique ne n'ose aller
devant les les gens en leur disant
voilà, il faut si vous voulez avoir le
système scolaire de santé, de protection
sociale euh de
de transport, les la taxation
vis-à-vis du en pour du du PIB,
tout le packaging,
c'est 44 %, je crois que c'est 44
44 45 % pour comparer aux États-Unis,
c'est 25. Donc, on est en en France, on
déjà on on on taxe beaucoup euh mais on
taxe pas de manière très progressive
euh et on et du coup, c'est pas une taxe
qui est très très efficace. On pourrait
avoir une taxe qui est beaucoup plus
progressive qui par là même serait
redistributive.
Euh donc
je suis tout à fait donc ça c'est un
c'est quand même un rôle du gouvernement
quoi qu'il même si je suis d'accord avec
vous que le gouvernement c'est aussi son
rôle de de de d'éviter qu'une crise
comme ça se se passe ou qu'on soit bien
prêt et on voit bien les différences
entre par exemple l'Allemagne et
l'Italie au tout début de la crise du du
Covid où l'Italie aessentiellement
absolument pas de de son système de
santé dans dans un état de de d'élite
mentel qui sont incapables de faire face
à la à l'arrivée du Covid. En plus, ils
ont pas eu de chance d'être les
premiers.
Alors, je vous rassure, c'était les
Allemands qui filaient des masques à nos
ressortissants à certains de nos
diplomates français en Chine. Je juste
pour la parenthèse,
tandis que les Allemands, ils étaient
beaucoup plus près en terme de lit
d'hôpital, en terme de ventilo et
cetera. Et donc le le le choc en terme
de mortalité a été très très différent
en Italie et en Allemagne. Et ça, on
voit bien que c'est le résultat d'années
de de politiques différentes dans les
deux pays. Donc c'est absolument clair
que euh les
c'est toujours on est toujours plus
intelligent après coup que avant.
Compare jamais au derniers de la classe
aussi.
Voilà.
On est toujours c'est c'est facile de
dire "Ah, on aurait dû le voir arriver
et cetera." Mais je me souviens que bah
moi je l'avais pas du tout vu arriver
mais absolument pas. Alors là en en
février, j'étais avec ma famille à New
York. On mangeait par terre
absolument aucune aucun sentiment qu'il
y avait quelque chose de de
pour manger par terre à New York. Je
sais où vous mangez par terre. quelque
chose de terrifiurant qui qui voilà on
avait confiance quoi.
Nous le 17 janvier, on avait des mecs de
notre communauté qui nous tenaient au
courant point par point des checkpoints
qui se déployaient en Chine.
Bah oui vous mais mais nous aussi
ça on le savait sur la Chine. Je me
souviens d'une conversation justement
mi-janvier où j'avais j'ai un collègue
chinois, un jeune collègue chinois qui
nous racontait ce qui se passait en
Chine. Mais on la réponse, j'en suis pas
fière mais je le je le dis comme c'est
en réalité c'est ils sont fous, c'est
Chinois. Enfin c'est incroyable.
Oui oui. Et euh
et maman là on disait quoi ?
Même en plein milieu du covid, elle elle
est elle y croyait pas complètement.
Enfin, elle était moins elle était moins
inquiète que moi. Elle usait off de
toute façon.
On va pas il était moins inquiète que
moi. Est-ce que vous
Mais mais je reviens en arrière, j'en
suis pas fière particulièrement parce
que justement tout au début du
tout au début du Oui, il faut bien finir
là, faut bien finir tout tout au début
du Covid
vraiment le tout début les le premier le
début du premier confinement vers le le
16 ou 17 mars, mes enfants étant à la
maison, on regarde une vidéo de C'est
pas sorcier qui datait de 10 ans.
avec Jamie
et Fred
et Fred et ils avaient un ils avaient un
invité euh qui leur parlait de de d'une
possible pandémie. Alors là, il parlait
de la grippe mais il décrivait
dans une précision absolue exactement
comment une pandémie euh pourrait
démarrer, euh comment elle circulerait,
ce qui pourrait se passer, c'était il y
a 10 ans. Donc
nous on avait Agnè Buisin.
Voilà. Donc c'est sûr que
il fallit lui envoyer la vidéo de FR des
Jamie peut-être. C'est sûr que ben moi
ça m'a frappé parce que
bah on se sent pas bien malin.
Pas juste Agè Busin mais
moi-même. C'estàd et comment ça se fait
que enfin c'était c'est pas c'était même
pas du du de la science très avancé qui
pouvait nous dire que une une pandémie
pouvait se produire, pouvait circuler à
une vitesse phénoménale.
Et j'ai j'ai eu la chance d'écouter
les deux fondateurs de BioTtech
qui qui discutait de comment ils se sont
mis à travailler sur sur leur vaccin
et il racontait que
dès le donc dès le début janvier, ils
ont vu ils ont ils ont commencé à suivre
ce qui se passait
et que le moment où ils ont compris
qu'il y aurait une pandémie effroyable,
c'est Le moment où il y a eu une où ils
ontù on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
une transmission asymptomatique,
c'est-à-dire qu'on pouvait transmettre
le virus avant de montrer des symptômes.
Et à ce moment-là,
c'est parce qu'ils sont mauvais parce
que quand ils sont rendus compte que
c'était aéroporté là la là c'était
l'ulcère de l'estomac avant.
Oui. Mais c'était mais mais la
transmission asymptomatique non c'était
tout au début. C'estàd ils s'en sont
rendus compte ils ils s'en sont rendus
compte. Donc c'était tout au début où il
y a une famille de une famille qui part
de vous sans aucun symptôme et un un
foyer ailleurs. On avait c'était en
janvier. On avait alors aucune idée de
comment ça se transmettait. Mais ils ont
à ce moment-là il s'est rendu compte
quelle que soit la manière dont ça se
transmet. Donc c'était avant que la
question des aérosols et cetera se pose.
Quelle que soit la manière dont ça se
transmet, ce truc va être une épidémie
épouvantable parce que les gens vont euh
euh vont vont la diffuser avant de
savoir qu'ils sont porteurs. Et euh et
du coup euh ils ont arrêté tout ce
qu'ils faisaient.
il travaillai sur le cancer euh leur et
ils ont tout laissé tout laissé tomber
leur programme et ils sont mis à
travailler sur le sur le vaccin. Et donc
on voit bien que cette
bah c'est leur métier hein mais mais
cette capacité de voir euh c'est et là
c'est pas de la prédiction parce que
c'était c'était vraiment être
professionnel.
C'est voilà c'est être professionnel,
aller jusqu'au bout de sa logique et de
dire il n'y a pas d'autres issu à cette
maladie. que euh une épidémie.
Alors moi je vais vous faire une
confidence puisqueon a fait deux trois
confidences sur votre maman.
Feu mon parin était le plus jeune
professeur en maladie infectieuse et
tropicale. Donc je me suis intéressé
très tôt à ce genre de bêtises. Quand
moi j'ai vu nos amis du gouvernement
coller des affichettes sanitaires à 4 à
Charles de Gaulle alors qu'il y a un vol
direct Charles de Gaulle.
À votre avis, quelle
quelle perception j'avais de mon
gouvernement ?
Vous allez sûrement le partager avec
nous.
J'ai ils étaient non chalants et
incompétents
pour rester euh
là aussi, je pense que contrairement à à
au fondateur de BioTech,
un nouveau c'est difficile hein de de
se mettre
voilà une façon dont je peux le dire,
c'est est-ce que si j'avais été dans
dans une position de de responsabilité
à ce moment-là, comment j'aurais réagi ?
Je sais pas. Et
pour préserver l'économie ?
Non, non, non. Juste est-ce que est-ce
qu' est-ce qu'ils ont compris ? Gen que
personne, très peu de gens ont compris.
Euh
par exemple, est-ce que quand Trump a
arrêté les premiers vols vers depuis la
Chine, enfin a dit, je veux plus avoir
de vol ? Poutine qui a arrêté les
premiers vols depuis la Chine
aux ÉAT mais aux États-Unis quand Trump
a dit on va arrêter les vols de la Chine
les gens ont dit mais c'est un scandale
faut pas des gens bien pensant donc
alors qu'en fait il se trouvait que dans
sa
sa folie cétait quand même
ma prochaine question est-ce que le fait
d'arroser les populations d'argent
public quand on fait des grosses bourdes
ça rend pas nos sociétés moins
résilientes et ça ne ça ne les ça a
tendance à les ramollir
non revenons en arrière
Ah oui.
Donc
d'accord.
Non
non puisque reprenons l'exemple du
Covid, si on narrose pas les gens à ce
moment là, on les laisse s'enfoncer dans
un dans un marage.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe si on on les
laisse s'enfoncer ?
Et ben, on a beaucoup de mal à en
sortir. C'est exactement ce qu'on a vu
dans les pays en développement.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui se passe dans les
gouvernements ? Ils sautent tous. Les
institutions sautent tous.
Non, ils sautent pas tous. Il y en a qui
sautent, il y en a qui sautent pas. en
Inde, on a laissé les gens euh
on a laissé les gens s'effondrer et
c'est le gouvernement n'a pas sauter. Ça
dépend pas forcément mais par contre ce
qui est clair c'est que les
gouvernements qui n'ont pas pu venir en
aide à leur population, les populations
ont mis beaucoup plus de temps à se
remettre
et l'économie dans son ensemble a mis
beaucoup plus de temps à se à se
remettre. Donc indépendamment de la de
la visée
de la visée, enfin c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure, c'est-à-dire
on on laisse pas les gens dépérir
euh parce que c'est bon pour eux ça les
rendra résilients. On prépare la
résilience, c'est clair. Je
parle du gouvernement, moi je parle pas
des gens. Bah oui, si vous arros si vous
si vous arrosez pas les gens quand ils
en ont besoin parce qu'ils font un face
parce qu'ils font face à quelque chose
comme le Covid, c'est les gens que
c'est un collapsus économique infiné.
Bah c'était c'était clairement le risque
et je pense que c'est ce qu'on a vu dans
les pays qui ont pas pu qui ont pas pu
se le permettre.
Alors j'aimerais qu'on parle maintenant
de guerre économique et de pauvreté.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire de la
guerre économique
entre qui et qui ? entre tout le monde.
Euh
c'est un sujet que vous connaissez pas
du tout un peu MIT on réfléchit. Est-ce
que la cantine on en parle ?
Ah je sais pas si on en parle exactement
dans ces termes.
À la cantine.
À la cantine ouais. Je sais pas si on en
parle exactement dans ces termes. C'est
pour ça que je vous demande entre qui et
qui parce que euh je veux m'assurer de
savoir exactement à quoi vous faites
référence pour pas répondre à côté de la
question.
Est-ce que la guerre économique c'est un
sujet que les économistes modélisent ?
Est-ce qu'ils sont sensibilisés à des
stratégies de guerre économique ? Est-ce
qu'il conseillent nos gouvernements en
terme de guerre économique ou est-ce que
c'est le soleil à la plage avec un peu
de crème solaire ?
la euh les économistes sont en général
en tant que profession hein ont tendance
à à à accorder une grande
à aimer beaucoup le commerce voilà la
coopération entre le peuple et le
commerce le plus libre possible.
Donc euh je moi je suis pas spécialiste.
Moi je le fais pas mais je pense pas que
ce soit fait de manière ce que vous avez
balancé là.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre entre
les lignes ?
Euh bah rien, je dis exactement les
économistes aiment le commerce. Est-ce
que le commerce fait partie en intégrité
de la guerre économique ? Ah, c'est un
on peut dire que on on c'est comme je
sais pas ce que c'est un guerre
économique, alors j'ai l'impression de
ne pas répondre à votre question
exactement correctement, mais euh le
Si je veux tuer un pays
pour lui prendre son marché, qu'est-ce
qu'il faut que je fasse ? Faut que je
lui fasse la guerre, faut que je
l'endette, faut que je crée des chômeurs
chez lui.
Euh,
faut que je crée des pauvres chez lui
pour le mettre sous le jou.
Oui, je pas j'espère que je pense pas
que ce soit quelque chose sur laquelle
travaillent les économistes. J'espère
que non, en tout cas, pas les
économistes, pas les économistes
d'université et pas ceux du MIT. Au
contraire, les économistes du MIT vont
plutôt se pencher sur la la concorde
entre les peuples. Ils sont peut-être un
peu naïfs sur le bien que enfin
l'économiste en général en tant que
profession que peut faire le commerce
international un peu aveugle sur les les
le climat, les pauvres. Ah oui, sur bah
sur les sur les de manière générale les
effets pervers
que ce soit euh les ce dont on parlait
par exemple avec les pauvres
avec les pauvres
aux États-Unis, enfin avec ceux qui
produisaient des meubles aux États-Unis
qui ont été écrabouillés par le par le
commerce. Ça c'est pas la Chine qui
faisait la guerre économique aux
États-Unis. C'est la Chine qui veut
vendre des meubles, qui essaie de la
Chine dont le tout le modèle économique
est est fondé sur euh l'exportation a
besoin de vendre des meubles. Donc jeen
voulais pas particulièrement au au
aux au aux gens de Caroline du Nord qui
ont perdu leurs emploi de donc souvent
c'est pas une question de J'ai
l'impression que la différence entre la
manière dont vous posez les questions et
et les réponses que je fais c'est que
vous voyez plus d'intentionnalité
dans les actions.
Super. puté
non c'est pour ça que j'ai dis j'ai
l'impression que vous voyez plus
d'intentionnalité dans les actions que
ce soit les actions du gouvernement des
entreprises et cetera et moi je vois
plus de
de
soit de de vision tonel
de hier de vision à e hier où on fait
pas attention aux effets secondaires de
ce qu'on fait soit à l'incompétence et
de manière générale vous vous demandiez
les critiques
On a digressé mais enfin vous a
longtemps vous demandiez les critiques
que
qu'on a pu
fait à notre à mon travail
et une critique qui est liée à celle de
ça ignore les côtés macroéconomiques et
tout ça c'est euh
euh
la le le quoi j'ai perdu le fil c'est
que Euh
euh
zut, où est-ce que j'en étais ? Pardon,
j'ai perdu le fil. Je vais je vais y
revenir. H
oui, c'est que le le la ça ignore les
contraintes politiques et que finalement
tout est déterminé par la politique, que
ce soit dans les pays riches, des
questions de lobbysme dont on parlait,
que ce soit dans les pays pauvres, la
corruption et tout ça et que ça
et ça ne laisse aucune place à à
l'action ou l'action pour améliorer les
performances scolaires dans les écoles,
c'est anecdotique par rapport à ces
grandes de force politique qu'on ignore.
Vous avez lu Raymond Aaron
et là où je suis, je vais revenir, je
vais répondre à cette question après
mais je vais juste finir la phrase avant
de perd perdre encore le fil mais là où
moi moi je suis je et ayant passé
beaucoup de temps sur le terrain à à
regarder ce qui se passe en pratique, je
vous dire qu'il y a une marge d'action
considérable parce que en plus des
grands systèmes politiques, de
l'intentionnalité et cetera, il y a
aussi une incompétence absolument
générale
par exemple sur le sur le par exemple le
fait que l'Italie soit soit pas prête.
C'est pas parce que pour avoir des
ventilateurs dans les hôpitaux, c'est
pas à cause de une mauvaise volonté.
C'est juste qu' ont pas pensé plus loin
que le bout de leur nez. euh en quand
les les fait que les les écoles que ce
soit en Inde ou en Afrique soient mal
organisé, que les enfants ont des
programmes beaucoup plus trop beaucoup
beaucoup trop difficiles pour eux,
beaucoup plus difficile que ce que nous
on fait d'ailleurs et donc sont
complètement perdus et donc
infini n'apprennent rien à l'école,
c'est pas parce que quelqu'un leur veut
qu' reste ignorant, c'est juste parce
que personne a pensé à aller regarder ce
qui se passait vraiment dans les écoles
avec les avec les les programmes
scolaires et et des enfants au niveau
très hétérogène et sans sans sans aide à
la maison. ma
ma
on en parle dans le dans dans repenser
la pauvreté mon livre de d'une dizaine
d'années qui a une dizaine avec Abid
Benergie on en parle on dit ce qu'on
retrouve ce qui ce qui vraiment
euh limite le plus l'efficacité de de la
politique économique dans les et en
particulier la cisation des plus pauvres
c'est 3 I idéologie ignorance inertie
Et l'idéologie, c'est euh elle peut être
euh capitaliste, anticapitaliste,
mais euh ou ni l'un ni l'autre, une très
forte intuition de comment les gens
vivent leur vie. Euh par exemple, on a
donné un exemple avec oh les les
pauvres, ça les remparais ceux si on les
aide trop. un exemple d'idéologie,
ignorance des réalités sur le terrain et
inertie quand quelque chose est mis en
place, il reste en place pour toujours.
Et du coup, on se retrouve avec que ce
soit dans les pays riches ou dans les
pays pauvres, un arsenal de politique,
d'action, de programme et cetera qui va
dans tous les sens et qui est juste
euh inutile ou même contre-productif.
Euh et donc il y a énormément de choses
à faire à un niveau assez modeste,
humble, technique euh pour améliorer
l'efficacité de l'action indépendamment
de en fait ils le veulent parce qu'ils
veulent nous garder dans cet état et
cetera. Je pense pas, je pense que ils
veulent pas du tout nous garder dans cet
état. Ils sont juste
euh pas compris comment nous en faire
sortir.
Vous êtes quel quel regard vous portez
sur les anti capitalistes et les
procapitalistes ? Vous êtes plus pour le
capitalisme ? Quel est le regard vous
vous avez sur le capitalisme à l'heure
actuelle ? Quel regard vous portez sur
les anticapitalistes ?
Pareil, moi je suis pas tellement grand
système. Je crois que la vérité de nos
systèmes économiques, c'est qu'on est
dans une espèce de système un peu
hybride où on a des éléments de
capitalistes, des éléments de
non capitalisme, des éléments de
gouvernement, des euh
vous dites non capitalisme parce que les
marchés financiers sont sous perfusion
dignes de l'AxUnion soviétique. Pourquoi
vous dites ça ?
parce que le capitalisme, il y a des il
y a des endroits où le capitalisme est
vraiment
dans une forme un peu assez pure puis il
y a des endroits où où il est pas. Il y
a des endroits où bah justement par
exemple le fait que
euh
parfois plus les entreprises sont
grandes, plus elles ont des subventions,
plus elles ont accès au plus elles ont
plus elles ont accès à un taux
d'imposition faible. On peut pas dire
que ce soit le capitalisme. Donc
c'est quoi ?
C'est notre système de c'est notre
système de société. Le nom m'intéresse
pas tellement. L'important, c'est c'est
dans quel système on vit, qui est dans
système hybride
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire dans le
système d'aujourd'hui. Alors après, il y
a d'autres gens qui réfléchissent plus à
au comment il faudrait réformer
l'ensemble du système
qui dont les philosophes, les personnes
certaines personnes plus abstraits en
sciences politiques qui vont nous dire
euh le système ou même les historiens
qui peuvent continuer qui peuvent nous
dire comment c'était dans le passé et
qui peuvent continuer le peuvent faire
des propositions basées là-dessus.
Moi mon travail de tous les jours, là où
je j'ai choisi de me ou de concentrer
mes efforts, c'est dans le monde
imparfait,
bordélique dans lequel on vit. Qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire ici et maintenant pour
améliorer la qualité de vie des gens les
plus pauvres du monde ?
Pourquoi vous avez choisi ça ? Parce que
vous aimez ça.
Non, c'est ça qui m'a choisi en quelque
sorte. J'ai toujours
Bah vous vous parliez de ma mère euh je
pense que ça a joué un rôle. Elle elle
était pédiatre, elle est à la retraite
aujourd'hui. Euh et elle travaillait
dans
dans un dans une enfin elle elle était
pédiatre de ville, mais elle avait elle
était aussi active dans une association
de de pédiatres
euh qui aidaient les enfants victimes de
victimes de la guerre qui s'appelle
l'appel.
Petite association. Euh et puis j'ai
aussi un oncle qui qui avait été euh qui
avait euh fait partie de la de la
création de médecin du monde. Et donc à
les écouter que soit ma mère en revenant
de de mission pour l'appel ou mon oncle
en revant de mission pour médecin du
monde nous raconter un petit peu les les
conditions de vie dans les pays où ils
allaient. Je me souviens le premier
voyage de ma mère, c'était chez les
Sarais et elle nous montrait des
diapositives. Je je pense que vous êtes
bah chez les Sarah. Oui, la question
justement la question était la question
était était sensible euh justement donc
parce que c'était des enfants victimes
de la guerre donc c'était la la le
conflit entre les Saroui et le et le
gouvernement marocain à l'époque. Euh
elle est revene, elle nous avait montré
des diapositives, vous souvenez des
diapositives avec un petit carré blanc
qu'on mettait dans des machines. Elle
montrait ça et je elle montrait des
photos
de de d'enfants qui allaient chercher de
l'eau très loin. Je devais avoir 8 ou 9
ans à son premier voyage.
Et ça m'a vraiment donné cette cette
plantée dans cette question de quelle
est ma responsabilité à moi dû au fait
que je suis née dans la classe moyenne
parisienne banlieu parisienne alors que
j'aurais pu naître au Sahara ou au Tchad
ou
dans un pays où
en tant que petite fille j'aurais passé
mes journées à aller chercher de l'eau
et j'aurais pas pu aller à l'école.
Enfin, j'avais une vision en plus
particulièrement noire de ce qui était
euh que d'être pauvre. Donc ça c'est une
question qui
je j'avais cette cette idée en moi
depuis depuis enfant que mon il fallait
que je trouve un moyen de de d'être
d'être utile pour les plus pauvres du
monde.
C'est pour ça que vous avez participé à
l'écriture de des cinq petits livres que
je vois à gauche. J'en vois que trois
d'ailleurs. Est-ce que vous pouvez me
montrer ça ? Oui, je vais vous montrer
ça avec plaisir.
Alors,
c'est pour Bruno Lemer. Est-ce qu'il y a
une version où il y a coloriage inclus
pour qu'on puisse envoyer à Bruno Lemèt
?
B je vais lui envoyer de toute façon.
Ils sont ils sont illustrés. C'est pas
au crayon de couleur mais mais chez Yan
Olivier l'illustratrice, elle travaille
à son son mode de travail c'est en
principe au crayon de couleur. Là c'est
intéressant parce qu'elle les a fait
pour elle a répliqué la technologie
crayon de couleur mais avec quatre
couleurs primaires pour que ça puisse
être imprimé même pour cher
pour pas cher. Exactement. Euh donc soit
dit en passant. Alors ces livres
ça vaut pour euh euh
chaque volume coûte 9,90 €. Où va
l'argent ?
Où va l'argent ? Au seuil. Euh le
toucher des sous dessus
euh un petit peu.
Et vous le donnez à qui après ?
Bah nous on le donne
aux impôts.
Voilà, aux impôts déjà. Et puis après
bah chez Yen en vie hein et pas très
bien. Et puis euh euh
et puis moi je le donne à tout un tas de
de causes auxquelles je donne mon
argent. Alors, ça parle de quoi ? C'est
à destination de qui ? Jusqu'à quel âge
?
Alors, ça parle de bah justement, ça
parle de Il y en a 10 au total. Euh, il
y en a eu cinq aujourd'hui. Euh, il y en
a eu cinq Il y a cinq qui qui paraissent
le 1er août. Euh euh
et puis il y en a cinq qui sont parus
l'année dernière.
Est-ce que vous pouvez ouvrir un
Je vous en ouvrir un pour que vous voyez
les illustrations de chez qui sont
vraiment magnifiques. Euh voilà. Là,
c'est le propriétaire terrien.
Il est tout rond. Alors, elle travaille
avec des formes géométriques
accumulées. Ça se passe dans un pays
pauvre, mais c'était très important pour
moi que ce soit pas
géographiquement localisé.
Est-ce que on peut faire ça avec la
France ?
Ah, alors on pourrait faire ça avec la
France, ce sera quelqu'un d'autre qui le
fera parce que moi je travaille pas
suffisamment sur la France pour être
pour pouvoir écrire sur les enfants.
C'est pas un pays suffisamment pauvre
pour qu'on ait le une prix Nobel qui
s'intéresse à nous. C'est ça.
Si si, mais ça pourrait être c'est juste
quelqu'un d'autre. C'est une question de
on peut pas on n pas on peut pas tout on
peut pas tout faire. Donc on est obligé
de choisir un domaine. Moi ce que j'ai
choisi c'est la pauvreté dans les pays
les plus pauvres. Mais c'est très
important de se prer de de la pauvreté
en France.
Donc j'espère que quelqu'un va écrire un
livre aussi sur la pauvreté dans le
monde là. Donc il y a il y a il y a 10
livres. Euh celui-là par exemple TPA
c'est sur c'est sur une petite fille qui
est un superhéros mais elle mais un
superhéros très tranquille.
Euh c'est une petite fille qui aime
beaucoup les arbres et il y a un risque
que les arbres soient coupés dans son
village. Donc cette dame lui raconte
qu'il y a longtemps dans son village, il
y avait eu une action à où les les
jeunes filles étaient attachées aux
arbres pour empêcher que qu'il soit
coupé. Et cette
ça c'est encore de la propagande
écotterroriste.
Oui.
À destination des petits-enfants.
Ah voilà, il faut commencer très tôt.
Donc cette cette
histoire, elle fait référence à une
vraie histoire. Vous pensez sans doute
que les premiers à s'attacher aux
arbres, c'était les les les IP en
Californie, mais pas du tout. C'était
des des dames en Inde euh le Chipco
Movement qui s'était accroché à des
arbres pour empêcher qu'il soit coupé
pour faire des raquettes de tennis.
Et donc elle décide la petite fille de
faire ça et elle se met à son arbre
et euh et c'est comme ça que et donc
après les bûcherons arrivent et elle lui
explique quelque chose suffisamment
longtemps pour qu'il hésite. Et c'est ça
son super pouvoir, c'est justement
d'expliquer pour qu'il hésite un tout
petit peu et après on voit les autres
intervenir. Et pour ça, moi, c'était
très important, c'est pour montrer aux
enfants que donc c'est destiné vous aux
enfants de de à peu près 5 à 7 ans euh
pour les pour être lu avec un adulte qui
peut être un grand frère, une grand-mère
et cetera.
Euh donc là, on voit qu'elle qu'elle
elle est attachée à son arbre, puis il y
a d'autres enfants qui arrivent, puis
ensuite il y a les adultes qui arrive
et finalement c'est le fait que tout le
village et la communauté s'associe à
cette action qui fait que les bûcherons
s'en s'en vont. Alors là, peut-être que
le livre traditionnel pour enfant se
serait arrêté là. Victoire, les
bûcherons s'en vont. Mais ce que j'aime
bien moi, c'est que les comme dans la
vie réelle, les
les les terroristes,
les les résolutions ne soient pas si
simples.
Et donc ils disent le à la page d'après,
il y a le alors d'abord, il y a il y a
la police, il y a la blabla TV qui vient
euh qui montre le mouvement, les les
bûches qu'on s'en vont, ils sont
contents. Après lui il dit mais c'est
bien sympathique mais la raison pour
laquelle ils avaient invité les
bûcherons d'abord c'est que toute leur
leur plantes avaient été grillé par la
chaleur. Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
maintenant ? Qu'est-ce qu'on va manger ?
C'est bien malin votre échoterrorisme
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Et donc du
coup il y a on voit que les choses sont
pas si simples et que et lui c'est pas
le personnage le plus sympathique du
livre mais il pose quand même une vraie
question.
Et euh après donc Blabla TV, elle leur
dit "Mais en fait, il y a des gens qui
sont prêts à payer pour euh protéger les
arbres." Et donc c'est là qu'on ça lie
au programme des des crédits carbone qui
fait que dans dans la vraie vie, c'est
possible. Il y a eu un programme qui a
été évalué par exemple en Ouganda où les
gens sont payés pour garder leurs
arbres. Alors, ils le font pas s'ils ont
pas envie de le faire, hein. Mais ça
peut les aider à garder leur crédit
carbone quand même.
Ah, beaucoup le il y a eu Attendez,
attendez, non. Ah,
donc on continue sur
la fin du bouquin. On va pas raconter
tout le bouquin.
Voilà, voilà, c'est fini là. Donc du
coup, il décide de de de de participer
au programme. Donc il
des notes explicatives pour les parents.
Voilà, il y a une note explicative pour
les parents.
Donc, en fait, il y a il y a trois voix
dans ces livres. Il y a des bulles parce
que les personnages parlent, se parlent
de temps en temps. Ça c'est la voix
spontanée des personnages. Une voix un
peu sobre, c'est la mienne disons qui
raconte l'histoire.
Et puis après il y a une note pour les
parents. Là c'est le recul euh qui donne
un peu de contexte, un peu
d'explication. C'est pas pour que les
parents transforment ces histoires en
des romans à clés, hein. Les histoires,
c'est des vraies histoires. J'espère
qu'elles intéresseront les enfants. Il y
a des caractères qui sont sympathiques.
Puis en plus, ils se développent sur 10
livres. Donc chaque livre d'ailleurs est
indépendant. Donc on peut choisir son
thème ou son caractère. Euh mais ça peut
quand même donner aux parents déjà les
rassurer un petit peu au cas où les
enfants posent des questions, leur
donner quelques éléments de réponse et
puis aussi euh utiliser les enfants
comme comme manière euh de peut-être
conduire leurs parents qui auraient pas
nécessairement naturellement
euh choisi un livre sur la pauvreté dans
le monde euh de s'intéresser un petit
peu au problèmes. Donc il y a la note
explicatique avec aussi des
illustrations.
Voilà. Donc il y en a 10 comme ça sur
des thèmes
comme bah la protection des arbres,
la corruption peut-être.
Il y a il y a euh il y a pas il y en a
pas un qui est directement sur la
corruption, mais il y en a un qui est
sur la démocratie locale et sur le fait
que en fait c'est un petit peu il y a un
petit peu de vote buying dans notre
démocratie de d'achat de vote dans notre
démocratie locale puisque
subordination de vote.
Nos subordination de vote. Exactement.
parce que notre propriétaire terrien là,
il essaie de
il pense que la manière dont il va être
élu, c'est en en donnant à tout le monde
des t-shirts et et des petits
des des gâteaux et cetera pour venir à
son meeting. Euh mais comme c'est quand
même une histoire qui se finit bien, la
la
Pourquoi ça se finit bien ? quand on
écrit des histoires pour les enfants,
elle surtout de cet âge là, c'est très
important c'est très important que ça se
finisse bien. Mais ce que j'essaie de de
faire, c'est que ça se finisse bien tout
enissant une ouverture, que c'est pas la
fin évidente, qu'il reste des questions,
une à une
la perception chez l'enfant puis chez
l'adulte aussi que bon, ça s'est bien
terminé mais euh ça aurait pu ça aurait
pu se dérouler autrement.
Question internet.
Madame Duflou, pourriez-vous parler du
rôle de la corruption dans la fabrique
de la pauvreté ?
Alors, d'abord, je pense que c'est ce
que aujourd'hui j'étais à Sciencep c'est
juste avant de venir à cet après-midi et
personne n'est parfait. Cette question
m'a été posée et j'ai répondu à la jeune
fille qui m'a posé la question :
"J'aimerais bien que vous euh que vous
gar que vous si vous deviez garder une
seule chose de ma conférence
aujourd'hui, c'est ne venez pas à la
corruption comme réponse facile à "Ah,
on peut pas aider les gens dans les pays
dans les pays en développement parce
qu'il y a trop de corruption." Parce que
dans la corruption, il y en a partout.
Il y en a dans les pays en
développement, il y en a dans les pays
développés, il y en a dans les
gouvernements, il y en a dans les
entreprises. Euh il y en a peut-être
plus dans les gouvernements parce qu'ils
essayent de faire des choses où ça va
vraiment contre le grain. Donc quand on
a des policiers qui veulent que vous
arrêtiez au feu rouge, c'est très
tentant de plutôt leur donner une leur
donner un petit pot de vin tandis que
les entreprises ont tendance à faire des
choses qui vont dans le sens du grain.
Donc la corruption est un problème. Elle
est pas la seule responsable de la de la
de la pauvreté.
Il y a il y a pas une seule cause à la
pauvreté de toute façon. Il y a tout un
faisceau de cause. La corruption en est
une mais l'incompétence toute simple en
est une aussi même pour des gens qui
sont ni corrompus ni
avec des mauvaises intentions. Euh et
d'autre part la corruption c'est aussi
un résultat. C'est pas seulement une
cause, c'est aussi un un effet un effet
de système qu'on peut qu'on peut
améliorer pour pour qu'il soit moins
sensible à la corruption. Par exemple,
il y a un programme en Inde de
je pour citer un exemple en Indonésie,
il un programme en Indonésie de riz de
distribution de riz aux aux personnes
pauvres
qui est financé centralement mais
administré dans chaque village parce que
programme a énormément de corruption. il
à peu près euh 30 % du riz qui devrait
arriver aux gens qui leur parvient
effectivement.
et euh le le gouvernement et des membres
de mon laboratoire dont à Abidjergie ont
fait une étude pour euh étudier comment
informer mieux les gens sur leurs droits
dans le cadre du programme euh pour
qu'ils puissent euh refuser la
corruption et savoir parce qu'ils savent
mieux ce à quoi euh euh ils pouvaient
prétendre. Et donc ils ont le ils ont
distribué les cartes avec euh monsieur
monsieur machin monsieur du flot a le
droit de recevoir tant de kiloderie à
tel prix. Et ensuite ils ont essayé
différentes versions des cartes pour
voir laquelle marchait la mieux. Et ce
qu'ils ont trouvé, c'est ce qui marche
le mieux, c'est non seulement de
distribuer à chaque personne une cadre,
mais aussi de mettre des posters partout
dans le village pour que tout le monde
sache que tout le monde sait euh que le
programme existe et quels sont les
droits. Et du coup, dans la négociation
avec le avec le euh la personne qui
l'administre localement,
la les les villageois sont les plus
forts. Donc on arrive, faut pas prendre
la corruption comme une fatalité en se
disant "Ah, il y a de la corruption,
c'est pour ça que les gens sont trop
pauvres." Faut prendre la corruption
comme quelque chose contre laquelle on
peut se battre.
Le salaire universel, qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez ?
Le revenu universel. Revenu revenu
universel.
Ça dépend de quel côté on se place.
Alors pour moi, je c'est différent dans
les pays pauvres et dans les pays
riches. Euh dans les pays pauvres
comme la France,
pas comme la France qui est un pays très
riche dans les pays pauvres comme le
Togo ou le Leso ou dans les vraies
économies pauvres. On a eu quand même
des émeutes de la pauvreté nous aussi en
France.
Oui, mais c'est pas des
récemment. On va revenir sur ce que je
ferai en France, mais dans dans les pays
dans les pays pauvres euh les
avoir un revenu euh de base universelle
euh qui garantisse à chacun un plancher
qui est que ce sera toujours possible de
nourrir votre famille. ça peut avoir un
effet extrêmement euh positif à la fois
sur l'initiative en disant voilà, je
peux prendre un risque parce que même si
je tombe, même si ça marche pas,
j'auraiis toujours la possibilité
d'avoir accès à ce revenu universel. Don
dans notre livre économie utile pour des
temps difficiles qui est paru en 2019,
on en parle quandme d'un revenu ultra
basique universel. C'estàd c'est un
revenu faible don à auquel tout le monde
peut peut prétendre quand ils en ont
besoin. Mais donc il faut quand même
aller le demander de par ça peut même
être par pour qu'il y ait pas de
corruption. Ça peut être simplement un
SMS sur le téléphone pour dire ce
mois-ci envoyez-moi les sous sur mon
compte. un truc vraiment très simple
mais euh disponible juste pour que les
gens
ne le dép ne le reçoit pas quand ils en
ont pas besoin parce que sinon les coûts
budgétaires sont énormes. Tandis que si
c'est un revenu très très faible mais
qu'il faut quand même faire un geste qui
disent je suis très pauvre ce mois-ci,
donnez-moi mon revenu.
Si j'ai un téléphone, si je sais écrire
et ainsi de suite.
Presque tout le monde a un téléphone.
C'est ça la beauté de de pas forcément
un smartphone mais l'accès à un
téléphone est quasiment universel
maintenant. aux transactions financières
par téléphone
et aux transactions financières par
téléphone. Donc c'est pour ça ça c'est
hein complètement révolutionner la donne
qui permet de de faire ce genre de
choses. Pendant le Covid par exemple, le
Togo l'a l'a expérimenté avec énormément
de succès. Après, ils avaient plus de
sous pour le pour le fiancer
malheureusement.
Donc donc ce serait donc pour les pays
les plus pauvres, c'est ce qu'on
propose. Un revenu ultra basique
universel.
Pour les pays riches,
un revenu de dignité, c'est beaucoup
plus que le revenu minimum qui
permettrait juste de manger.
Les gens pour vivre dignement, ils ont
besoin de de de beaucoup d'argent et du
coup si on voulait avoir un revenu
universel
c'est quoi beaucoup d'argent ? les les
chiffres que les gens euh font circuler
par exemple aux États-Unis pour un
revenu universel de base, ce serait
12000 € euh par euh par euh au moins par
je sais parfois c'est par famille,
parfois c'est par euh par individu,
par an, par mois, par quoi ?
Par par mois. Par an 12000 par mois,
donc à peu près 1000 € par mois. Euh
1000 € par mois.
C'est combien SMIC en France ?
Euh je sais pas combien le SMIC mais
c'est pas tellement euh au-delà de ça.
Pourquoi maintenant on dit reste à vivre
quand on a tout payé ? On dit rest ce
qui reste. Voilà, c'est un nouveau c'est
un concept. Oui, ça permet de se dire
qu'est-ce qui est quelle est la dépense
discrétionnaire une fois que qu'on a
payé le l'électricité, le loyer,
le téléphone euh
tout ça c'est
euh donc mais dans les revenus dans donc
pour avoir un un
dans dans ce que les gens recherchent,
que ce soit dans les pays riches ou dans
les pays pauvres, c'est pas juste de
survivre, c'est de vivre dans la dignité
dans dans des pays où il y a beaucoup de
richesse autour de soi. Le niveau de
revenu minimal pour vivre dans la
dignité, il est donc ben on peut
discuter sur les détails, mais il est
pas ultra basique. Et pour donner à
chacun le droit à ce type de revenu, il
faudrait des ressources fiscales
considérables.
Euh donc soit enlever tout ce qu'on a
d'autre comme politique sociale,
éducative et cetera, euh soit augmenter
encore les impôts,
pas un petit peu mais beaucoup, ce qui
paraît très difficile à faire.
Le seuil de pauvreté dans le nom, c'est
combien
en ce moment ? Aujourd'hui, ça en fait
c'est une quantité qui augmente
progressivement mais aujourd'hui c'est
de 2 dollars 15 par jour et par personne
à en en prenant en compte le le
pouvoir d'achat.
Donc c'est 2 dollars l'équivalent de 2
dollars pour vivre aux États-Unis.
Euh donc on voit bien que le le seuil de
pauvreté
international, il y a très peu de gens
qui vivent en dessous de ce pauvreté en
de ce seuil de pauvreté en France. Mais
en France, dans un pays comme la France,
on est pauvre avec beaucoup même si on a
beaucoup plus d'argent que cela.
Simplement parce que la pauvreté c'est
pas juste un concept absolu, c'est aussi
un concept relatif. Quand il y a une
mère isolée avec un enfant qu'elle a
tout payé, qu'elle subit le choc
énergétique, l'inflation alimentaire et
qu'il lui reste 30 € pour vivre pour le
mois.
Bah, elle est alors ça dépend
quand on compte c'est 2 dollars par jour
et par personne, euh c'est sans compter
le loyer, mais c'est pour mais c'est en
comptant tout le reste.
Euh donc ça dépend ce que vous mettez
dans dans le reste à vivre. Mais oui, il
se peut qu'il y a des gens qui vivent
avec pas tellement plus que que ça une
fois qu'on est une fois qu'on a et c'est
possible de vivre avec ça mais c'est
juste épouvantable
de survivre.
C'est possible de survivre avec ça mais
c'est juste épouvantable. Et donc le
revenu minimal s'il y en avait un en
France, il faudrait qu'il soit beaucoup
plus élevé que de mettre les gens au
seuil de pauvreté universelle. Or ça
coûterait énormément d'argent. Mais en
France, on a quand même l'avantage
d'avoir beaucoup de données sur
sur les sur les gens. on a beaucoup plus
de données, on a la capacité de de de
prévoir ou et et de et de et de
concentrer les aides sur certaines
personnes qui en ont plus besoin que
d'autres. Donc pourquoi ne pas le faire
? Donc plutôt que de faire quelque chose
d'universel, plutôt que faire un revenu
universel, faire un une garantie
universelle que personne devrait avoir à
vivre comme la mer isolée que vous
décrivez.
Est-ce qu'il faut fliquer les pauvres
avec leur data ?
Euh non, ni les pauvres ni les riches et
on n pas besoin de on n pas besoin de
fliquer les gens pour pouvoir faire un
pour pouvoir faire un ciblage. Par
exemple, on revient à mon exemple de la
des entreprises de meubles
euh aux États-Unis, il y avait pas
besoin de cibler qui que ce soit
individuellement. C'était parfaitement
clair que le secteur de l'ameublement
aux États-Unis allait souffrir de
l'entrée de la Chine dans le commerce
international. Donc si on avait voulu,
on aurait pu mettre en place un un un
support financier pour pour ces
familles. Et d'ailleurs, le mécanisme
existe, ça s'appelle Trade Adjustment
Act. Donc en principe, il y a un budget
pour venir en aide aux gens dont les le
l'emploi a été coupé par par la
concurrence avec le commerce
international. simplement euh il y a
très très peu d'argent qui a été dépensé
par ce programme
parce que la Chine ne voulait pas qu'on
mette des taxes à l'entrée sur la
frontière américaine. Donc non, rien à
voir. C'est pas du tout le choix de la
Chine, c'est les États-Unis
qui qui voulaient pas mettre de taxe à
l'entrée.
Qui voulaient pas non, c'est les
États-Unis qui voulaient pas. Étant
donné qu'il y avait pas de taxe à
l'entrée, on savait que les personnes
qui vivaient en Caroline du Nord
souffriraient. Il aurait été possible de
mettre en place un programme qui les
soutiennent. Et le mécanisme en principe
existait. simplement, il y avait pas
assez il y a pas assez d'argent qui a
été placé dedans. Euh donc tout ça pour
dire que c'est pas besoin de fliquer qui
que ce soit individuellement hein. Il
suffis de savoir dans quel secteur les
gens habitent ou même dans quelle
région, dans quel compté les gens
habitent et on aurait pu les soutenir
financièrement mais ça a pas été fait.
Ça c'est un choix c'est un choix
politique.
Est-ce que vous êtes vous avez porté
votre regard sur la fraude sociale ? ce
qu'on appelle la fraude sociale. Et
est-ce que vous avez fait vous avez
porté votre regard sur la fraude
fiscale,
l'évasion fiscale ou l'optimisation
fiscale ?
Ah moi pas directement, j'ai pas j'ai
pas fait tellement de recherches ni sur
un sujet ni sur l'autre. Mais par
contre, il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont
fait des recherches très intéressantes
là-dessus comme par exemple Gabriel
Zugman sur Gabriel Zucman qui a
travaillé sur l'optimisation fiscale, la
fraute fiscale et cetera. He et ce qui
est évident c'est que la faute sociale
quantitativement par rapport à la fraute
fiscale c'est même pas dans le même
c'est même pas dans le même ordre de
grandeur. Donc de toute façon, c'est ça
ça lie à nouveau avec
ce dont on parlait avant, c'est le
discours paresseux et cetera.
Culpabilisateur que je trouve
simplement ne pas être en adéquation
avec la réalité. Et c'est vrai que vite
on passe de ce discours moralisateur à
aux abus et cetera alors que les les
erreurs, il y en a plus dans l'autre
sens. Est-ce que
c'est-à-dire il y a plus de gens qui
auraient droit à des à des à des
services ou des droits et et qui ne les
réclament pas.
Donc le non recours est un programme un
problème qui typiquement est plus est
plus grave que celui de des abus.
Quand vous discutez avec les personnes
en première ligne face à la pauvreté,
est-ce qu'ils vous ont parlé
du du de la charge psychique
du fait d'être pauvre ? Est-ce que parce
que ils sont exposés avec leur téléphone
portable à la culture occidentale où
tout le monde fait des bouchons en
canard, on roule tous en Ferrari et tout
ira bien.
C'est quelque chose qu'on qui est qui
est particulièrement
prenant et flagrant, qui est plus
particulièrement prenant et flagrant
dans les pays riches que dans les pays
pauvres. Euh et en particulier euh le le
travail d'ATD Carmond euh qui est en en
une association qui qui est vraiment euh
donne une voix aux pauvres. Euh grâce à
eux, j'ai pu j'ai pu discuter avec des
gens en situation de pauvreté qui sont
dans une
dans une détresse qui sont souvent dans
une détresse psychique très profonde euh
justement parce que bah ils voient
d'autres façons de vivre et aussi parce
que on leur ramène tout le temps
justement ce discours là qui qui
retrouve du haut en bas de la hiérarchie
de leur conseiller à à au président fait
qu'il se sentent toujours ils se sentent
exclus Ils se sentent pas soutenus dans
les pays pauvres. La une grande partie
de la pauvreté au moins il y a aussi des
problèmes de santé mentale dans les pays
pauvres hein. Mais une mais
il y a moins de de stigmatisation de la
pauvreté. C'est fait plus partie du
paysage
normal classique.
L'intelligence artificielle pour régler
le la pauvreté, vous y croyez ? Vous y
croyez pas ?
Pour moi, pour pour l'instant, c'est un
slogan, je vois pas trop à quoi euh euh
ça correspond. Euh ce que je vois dans
l'intelligence artificielle, c'est
plutôt que ça risque de de le le en
particulier de développement des des
langages euh des large language model,
je sais pas comment on dit en français,
euh
va risquer de de supprimer un nombre
considérable d'emplois en particulier
par exemple en Inde qui sont des good
jobs, qui sont des emplois ou de classe
moyenne, de programmeurs, de gens qui
travaillent dans les dans les dans les
réseaux, dans les dans les centres
d'appel. Donc ça, je pense que l'effet
premier de de la vague actuelle
d'intelligence artificielle bagée sur
ces sur ces grands modèles, ça va pas
être de résoudre de la pauvreté. C'est
le contraire.
Quand on entend
des consommateurs pour décrire les
pauvres,
est-ce que comme on n pas de proposition
politique, on voit pas vers l'avenir, on
est obligé d'inventer des mots.
Oui. B moi je le connaissais pas ce mot.
Alors vous l'avez inventé pour moi ? Non
non, on l'a pas inventé pour vous, je
vous jure.
Des consommateurs.
Ouais, des consommateurs, c'est un peu
comme croissance négative.
Et ben, c'est un petit peu euh c'est un
petit peu ce qu'on le contraire de ce
qu'on essaie de faire dans ces livres.
Euh une des façons une une des
représentations de la pauvreté dans il y
a plusieurs
il y a plusieurs stéréotypes qu'on
retrouve sur les pauvres. On a beaucoup
parlé du pauvre paresseux. Euh une autre
un autre stéréotype qu'on retrouve
beaucoup, c'est le pauvre un peu
héroïque qui est poétique, magnifique
dans sa pauvreté, les couleurs spia,
voilà la personne la dont la sobriété
devrait nous inspirer. Alors que la
plupart des gens vraiment très pauvres
dans le monde, ce qu'il voudrait c'est
consommer un peu plus pour être pour
vivre mieux.
Votre philosophe préféré ?
Euh bah euh Quant probablement c'est pas
très original comme réponse mais c'est
votre philosophe préféré indien.
Alors euh
est-ce que
Martiè
[Musique]
compte comme philosophe
peut-être ? Oui. Il est entre la
philosophie et l'économie.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté
qui ont marqué votre vie ou qu'il faut
lire absolument
sur toute ma vie ou que j'ai lu
récemment
? Sur toute votre vie. Donc récemment,
ça rentre dedans.
Oui oui, c'est ça. Mais je voulais
savoir le le la
durée de la durée sur lequelle je euh
je dois
Vous êtes pas bien vieille quand même ?
Oui oui sur toute ma vie sur euh euh
euh
c'est ça 72
down and out in Paris and London.
En français, ça donne quoi ?
Euh
c'est sur
beautiful accent. Euh euh c'est sur euh
euh
la
c'est je sais pas comment c'est traduit,
c'est le euh
la vie de quelqu'un euh dans le système
de protection sociale anglaise. Euh donc
tout ce dont je parlais sur l'Angleterre
victorienne et cetera, c'est un un c'est
pas un livre de fiction. Euh c'est
vraiment euh ça m'a tout appris sur euh
le danger de de cette de cette è
victorienne.
Euh euh
donc ça c'est vraiment exceptionnel.
C'est 150 pages euh absolument
remarquable.
Euh
alors la traduction c'est dans la DHE à
Paris et à Londres. Voilà, c'est ça.
Merci.
Il y en a qui suivent.
Il y en a qui suivent, c'est très bien.
Ensuite,
le deuxème
donc ça c'est un un roman disons c'est
un mémoire mémoire dans
Raymond Aon.
Euh je le mettrai pas dans les dans les
livres qui m'ont
qui m'ont qui m'ont façonné.
Et la poésie de Renéchard.
Alors, je vais peut-être en donner un
petit peu plus que trois parce que la
poésie de Rchard, c'est en plus.
Faites-vous plaisir.
Euh,
un livre tout à fait intéressant sur
cette question justement de compétences
versus corruption.
Euh, c'est à nouveau, je vais vous
donner le titre en anglais. J'espère
qu'il est traduit en français. C'est
Imperial Life in the Emerald City, vie
impériale dans la cité d'Émeraude. C'est
sur la la zone verte à Bagdad après
l'invasion
euh l'invasion amé américaine au en
Irak.
Amé dans la zone verte, les Américains à
Bagdad.
Voilà.
Euh un autre livre de Non non fiction
qui m'a beaucoup inspiré
à nouveau en anglais. Ah ben je peux
peut-être traduire. Nous souhaitons vous
informer que demain nous serons tués
avec notre famille sur le génocide au
Rwanda et le rôle particulier de la
France.
Euh donc c'est tout ça, c'est des livres
relativement récents mais qui ont joué
un rôle qui m'ont vraiment éclairé sur
le toutes les questions qu'on qu'on se
posait qu'on se posait ensemble
euh
plutôt
euh euh meurtre dans la cathédrale de
Elliot, meurder de cathédrales qui est à
la fois politique et et poétique.
Voilà, ça vous fait un petit nombre.
C'est aux quelles éditions les petits
bouquins que vous avez ?
Le seuil jeunesse.
Le seuil jeunesse. Vous vous nous les
remontrez vous nous les montrez. Je vous
pose la question histoire
qu'on puisse réfléchir en même temps.
On a pas montré Célie. Alors on va
montrer un sur l'entrepreneuriat.
Euh elle essaie de monter sa petite
entreprise et elle a vraiment beaucoup
de mal et elle a besoin de un moment où
elle a besoin d'aide.
Et celui-là c'est sur les pénuries d'eau
dû au fait que on produit du riz. Là, on
devrait pas produire du riz parce qu'il
y a pas du tout assez d'eau.
La Thaïlande en ce moment est en train
de demander à ses producteurs de riz de
lever le pied de en terme de production
de riz.
Oui. Encore en Thaïlande, il y a il y a
il y a de l'eau. Si on regarde le punjab
en Inde, ça fait longtemps qu'ils
auraient dû lever le pied.
Quand tu regardes la nappe fréatique du
painjob, ça fait mal.
Voilà. Et ben, on peut c'est un peu le
background de de ce livre là.
Euh, est-ce que vous avez un conseil
pour les jeunes générations ? une
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable qui restera sur
l'internet
euh pour toujours et toujours. Euh
aimez ce que vous faites et faites ce
que vous aimez. Je essayer de faire un
peu moins
un peu moins poncif. Ah, vous l'avez
fait hein.
Euh euh mais dans c à cette occasion euh
c'est euh mais peut-être c'est quand
même la même chose, c'est-à-dire ça plus
cultiver votre jardin, c'est-à-dire
l'idée euh que pour changer le monde euh
on commence par un petit problème qu'on
essaie de vraiment comprendre et de
vraiment résoudre et puis après on passe
au problème d'après. Et après devant un
petit problème, on peut se dire "Mais
j'ai rien changé du tout là, j'ai changé
la vie de trois personnes mais ça
changer le monde pour ces trois
personnes là. Et si c'est une fonction
exponentielle quand on change les
choses, c'est très très bien."
Exactement.
Esther Duflo, merci.
C'est moi qui vous remercie.
[Musique]